FIVE IF I HAVE
YOUR ATTENTION GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND CALL THE LABOR EMPLOYMENT
MEETING OF WEDNESDAY FOR TWENTY
FOUR TO ORDER.
WE'RE GONNA START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE OF ONE I IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME AND OUT OF
RESPECT OF THOSE THAT ARE HERE.
AND ARE CERTAINLY THE MEMBER
THAT'S HERE ON TIME -- FOODS AND
JUST ALREADY KNOWS ABOUT A HALF
A DOZEN OR SO OTHER COMMITTEE
HEARINGS GOING ON SO.
THE MEMBERS ARE HERE NOT BECAUSE
THEY'RE GIVEN OFFICE BECAUSE
THEY'RE ACTUALLY IN OTHER
COMMITTEES AT PRESENT IN OTHER
COMMITTEES AND SO THEY'LL BE
MAKING THEIR WAY HERE --
HOPEFULLY -- IN SHORT ORDER BUT
IN THE MEANTIME I'D LIKE TO ASK
SOME OF OUR RAMOS P. LIKE TO
COME TO THE DESK -- BUT IT TO
THE DAY IS THERE.
THE AND FOR THE TABLE THERE AND
PRESENT ON ITEM EIGHTEEN WHICH
AB.
FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND JUST SO
AS A MEMBER RAMOS AND ANY OTHER
FOLKS ARE HERE AS WITNESSES ONE
I'LL BE.
MENTIONING THIS AS OTHER AUTHORS
COME IN -- THE WAY THAT I WON
THE MEETING IS THAT EACH SIDE
CAN HAVE UP TO SIX MINUTES.
AND YOU CAN CHOOSE HOWEVER WANT
TO BREAK IT DOWN ONE WITNESS TO
IT IS THREE MINUTES YOU
CERTAINLY DO NOT HAVE TO TAKE
ALL THE TIME WITH YOUR WITNESSES
EITHER -- AND SO WITH THAT --
MISS RAMOS PLEASE.
THANK YOU A A MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WHEN THEY ARE HERE THEY
DON'T KNOW THAT I OFFERED
GREETINGS TO THEM.
AND THIS IS ON A BE A FIFTY
FIFTY EIGHT REQUIRES A SCHOOL OR
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY. TO
CONTACT LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS -- PRECEDING A COLLEGE
OR CAREER FAIR.
ENSURING THAT STUDENTS ARE MADE
AWARE OF AND HAVE ACCESS TO
LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS SERVE A
VARIETY OF IMPORTANT PURPOSES
BOTH ARE EXPANDING THE SKILLED
WORKFORCE AND PROVIDING
APPRENTICES COMPETITIVE WAGES.
THE EARN AS YOU LEARN MODEL HAS
PROVEN TO BE EFFECTIVE IN
PROVIDING ACCESS AND OPPORTUNITY
TO THE JOB MARKET FOR ALL
WORKERS.
WHILE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
HAVE CLEAR BENEFITSFOR STUDENTS.
THE CURRENT ACADEMIC CLIMATE IN
HIGH SCHOOLS OFTEN EMPHASIZES
COLLEGE PREPAREDNESS WHILE THE
BENEFITS AND OPPORTUNITIES OF
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS FOR
STUDENTS.
EXITING HIGH SCHOOL ARE COMMONLY
OVERLOOKED.
EVEN IF STUDENTS WERE PROVIDED
THE INFORMATION ON THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS OF APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS.
THEY ARE OFTEN UNAWARE OF WHAT
LOCAL APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
ARE AVAILABLE AND HOW TO ACCESS
THEM.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT REQUIRES
A SCHOOL OUR LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCY TO CONTACT LOCAL
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
PRECEDING OF COLLEGE OR CAREER
FAIR.
THIS ENSURES THAT APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE GIVEN THE SAME
FORUMS TO PRESENT OPPORTUNITIES
TO STUDENTS AS OTHER COLLEGE OR
CAREER OPTIONS.
THIS BILL ALSO IMPROVE CHANNELS
OF COMMUNICATION BETWEEN LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES AN
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS BY
PROVIDING POINTS OF CONTACT AND
LOCATIONS OF OPERATION FOR LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES.
THIS PRACTICE WILL ENSURE THAT
STUDENTS ARE MADE AWARE OF THE
BENEFITS OF APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS AND THE SCHOOLS AND
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES ARE
EFFECTIVELY COMMUNICATING WITH
THE REGIONAL WORK FORCE AND THE
DEMAND.
THAT SO THERE [inaudible]
THANK.
WELL THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT YOU HAVE.
KNOWING THIS IS SUPPORT WHEN YOU
HAVE A GREAT JOB THANK I DON'T
THINK YOU NEED ANY WITNESSES
ABOUT EUROPE.
HI IS ANYONE LIKE SPEAKING
SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY WELL I THINK IS A GREAT
IDEA I REMEMBER CAREER FAIRS
I'VE BEEN TO THEM -- AS A YOU
KNOW AS A YOUNG PROFESSIONAL
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL I USED TO
GO TO AND YOU'RE RIGHT WE DON'T
HAVE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
THAT ARE BEING HIGHLIGHTED THE
TRADES.
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES AT AND
THAT'S A GREAT IDEA AND SOFULLY
SUPPORTED IT DOES ENJOY A
RECOMMENDATION OF AN AYE FROM
THE CHAIR.
AND SO WE GET A QUORUM -- WILL
BRING IT UP FOR A VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER ON A LEVELS.
THANK YOU.
BY SEE ANYBODY OUT THERE AWESOME
THIS WAY.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANKS.
NO I DO I DO I BILLS WITHIN OF
THE ODD TO PRESENT TO MYSELF.
AND BUT WE DO HAVE MISTER JONES
SAWYER MISTER JONES SAWYER --
BUT HIS BILLS ON CONSENT SO
ACTUALLY WHAT -- YES.
ASIDE TWENTY ONE YEAH.
SO YOU DO HAVE.
ONE ARE YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT
ON THAT MISTER JONES SAWYER. ONE
METER WITH.
AS A STARTED AND SO YEAH IT
WOULD.
CAN I CAN I GET A WITNESS.
AND SO AS I IN HERE EARLIER --
EACH SIDE IT HAS UP TO A SIX
MINUTES TO PRESENT OF ANY
WITNESS TESTIMONY MISTER JONES
SAWYER A. B..
TWELVE NINETY ONE THANK YOU THIS
BILL SO GOOD I DON'T THINK I
NEED A WHOLE SIX MINUTES.
SO ARE YOU YOU'RE NOT RESTRICTED
TO THE TIME ALTHOUGH I RESPECT
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS --
AB TWELVE NINETY ONE CLARIFIES
THE TIME FRAME FOR WHEN CANNABIS
BUSINESSES NEED TO COMPLY WITH.
LABOR PEACE AGREEMENT
REQUIREMENTS LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT IS AN AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE BUSINESS AND A LABOR
ORGANIZATION THAT PRESCRIBES THE
OBLIGATIONS OF EACH PARTY.
THESE AGREEMENTS TEND TO INCLUDE
MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL PROVISIONS
THAT PROTECT BUSINESSES AND
FACILITATE THE ABILITY FOR
EMPLOYEES TO ORGANIZE CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES THAT CANNABIS
BUSINESSES WITH MORE.
WITH TWENTY OR MORE EMPLOYEES
INTERRELATE FOR PEACE AGREEMENT
WITH THE UNION AS PART OF THE
APPLICATION PROCESS TO OBTAIN A
CANNABIS LICENSE.
BUSINESSES ARE REQUIRED TO STATE
THAT THEY WILL ENTER LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT IF THE BUSINESS HAD
NOT ALREADY ENTERED.
ONE HOWEVER CURRENT REGULATIONS
ARENOT CLEAR OF WHAT ON WIND
THIS RE REQUIREMENT NEEDS TO BE
FILLED.
REGULATIONS SAY THAT THESE
REQUIREMENTS SEEM TO BE MET AS
SOON AS REASONABLY PRACTICABLE
WOW THAT'S A BIG WORD WHICH IS
VAGUE AND OPEN TO INTERPRETATION.
A. B. TWELVE NINETY ONE WERE
REQUIRE BUSINESSES WITH TWENTY
EMPLOYEES OR MORE TO ENTER LABOR
PEACE AGREEMENT WITHIN SIXTY
DAYS OR EMPLOYING THEIR
TWENTIETH EMPLOYEE.
THIS MEASURE WILL PREVENT
ARBITRARY ENFORCEMENT AGAINST
CANDICE BUSINESSES AND PROVIDE
EMPLOYEES WITH CLARITY ON WHEN
AN EMPLOYER IS FAILING TO COMPLY
WITH THE LAW.
WITH ME TO DAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE IS JAZZY
GRAY WALL FROM UFC W..
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BOAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR AT
JAZZ YOU GRAY ALL REPRESENTING
YOUR C. W. WESTERN STATES
COUNCIL OUT OVER THE PAD
SPONSORS THAT AB.
TWELVE NINETY ONE I'M AND I'M
HERE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
THE MICROPHONE SET UP FOR
SUPPORT [inaudible]
YEAH.
MR TO REMEMBERS MITCH SNIDER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MATT BROWN WITH
THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WELL.
ANY ERA COMMENTS IN WELL FIRST
OF ALL I APPRECIATE BEING THIS
BILL THAT DOESN'T JOY AND I
RECOGNIZE FROM THE CHAIR AND
THAT'S ONLY BECAUSE I WENT TO
THE SUIT OUR CONSULATES RIGHT IN
OAKLAND.
NOTHING TO DO WITH IT -- ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU --
SNOOP DOGG.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PLEASE --
PRESENT ON A. B..%
ONE SIXTY AND EACH SIDE HAS UP
TO WE'RE NOT REQUIRED TO USE SIX
MINUTES FOR EXPERT TESTIMONY --
IF YOU HAVE ANYONE THAT YOU LIKE
TO TESTIFY OTHERWISE WHICH WILL
HELP PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES I THINK I'M THE
EXPERT.
I'M NOT A I HAVE THE PLEASURE OF
PRESENTING AB. ONE SIXTY FOR THE
EIGHTH YEAR IN A ROW.
A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW A
PRIVATE EMPLOYER THE ABILITY TO
ENACT A VOLUNTARY VETERANS
PREFERENCE PROGRAM.
THE VOLUNTARY VETERANS
PREFERENCES RECOGNIZE THAT
ENJOYED AMONG PUBLIC EMPLOYERS
HOWEVER PRIVATE EMPLOYERS ARE
LIMITED TO ONLY VIETNAM WAR HERO
THE VETERANS WHEN EXERCISING
THEIR VOLUNTARY VETERANS
PREFERENCE.
AND IT'S OBVIOUS THAT MOST
VIETNAM VETERANS LIKE MYSELF.
OR RETIREE OR LEAVING THE LABOR
FORCE SO.
THAT PREFERENCE DOESN'T REALLY
HELP ANYBODY.
AB ONE SIXTY SIMPLY REVISES AN
UPDATE OVERSIGHT BY ALLOWING
PRIVATE EMPLOYERS TO EXERCISE
OUR VOLUNTARY VETERANS
PREFERENCE TO ALL VETERANS WITH
THE GENERAL OR HONORABLE
DISCHARGE.
REGARDLESS OF THE ERA IN WHICH
THEY SERVE.
SIMILAR VOLUNTARY VETERANS
PREFERENCE PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN
ENACTED IN THIRTY SEVEN STATES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND HAVE
MANAGED TO STAY COMPLIANT WITH
THE CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR NONE OF THESE STATES
HAVE BEEN SUED.
SO WORKS.
AND IT BURKE HABITS
DISCRIMINATION IN HIRING THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT THERE'S NO
REASON CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT BE
CAPABLE F THE SAY.
I UNDERSTAND AND ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. FOR THOSE
REASONS MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS TO TO
CLARIFY -- THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- AS SOME MAIN.
NO TWELVE DAYS AGO THE
TRANSGENDER BAM INTO A FACT --
BUT THIS ADMINISTRATION PUT IN
PLACE THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT IS
TO MAKE THE BILL'S PROVISIONS
CONTINGENT ON REVERSAL OF THE
TRANS GENDER BAND AND ARMED
FORCES.
AND THIS PRESUMPTION OR ALSO
MAKING SURE THAT NO OTHER
PROTECTED CLASSES ARE DENIED OF
A SERVICE IN THE MILITARY I DO
APPRECIATE.
THE AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THAT
AMENDMENT WITH THE RECOGNITION
THAT UNTIL EVERYONE CAN SERVE --
THAT THAT -- THAT THIS PART THAT
THIS PROGRAM EVEN THOUGH IT
APPLIED ALL VETERANS -- WOULD
EXCLUDE SOME IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE
ACCEPTANCE OF THAT COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT -- MISTER VOEPEL.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ALICE KESSLER HERE ON
BEHALF OF A QUALITY CALIFORNIA
AND WHILE WE CERTAINLY APPLAUD
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS EFFORTS --
TO INSURER EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR VETERANS -- EVEN
WITH THE AMENDMENT THAT THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
UNFORTUNATELY WE DO HAVE
REMAINING CONCERNS -- BUT FIRST
JUST FUNDAMENTALLY -- THE WAY
THIS IS STRUCTURED -- TO GIVE A
PREFERENCE TO ONE GROUP THAT'S
PROTECTED UNDER FEE HA -- IT YOU
KNOW IT DOES DISADVANTAGED THE
OTHER PROTECTED GROUPS -- UNDER
THE LAW AND AND THAT IS
PROBLEMATIC FOR US.
IN ADDITION -- YOU KNOW DON'T
ASK DON'T TELL WAS ONLY LIFTED
IN TWENTY ELEVEN THERE ARE MANY
YEARS WHERE MANY MEMBERS OF THE
LGBT COMMUNITY WERE.
EXCLUDED FROM MILITARY SERVICE
AND WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO BENEFIT
FROM THE PREFERENCE -- AND AS
WELL THE CURRENT BAND -- AND ALL
OF THE FOLKS THAT ARE GONNA BE
PRECLUDED WHILE THAT BAND IS IN
PLACE -- SO UNFORTUNATELY FOR
THOSE REASONS WE WE MUST OPPOSE
THE BILL BUT WE CERTAINLY DO.
APPRECIATE THE ASSEMBLY MEN'S
EFFORTS -- AND AND INTENT WITH
THE BILL THANK YOU THE PROJECT
THAT ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MARIE GO YOUR SHE HARD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION.
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION --
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THE
BILL AND YOU KNOW OUR OUR
ATTORNEYS REPRESENT SERVICE
MEMBERS AND VETERANS AND
DISCRIMINATION AND USER TYPE
ACTIONS AND UNDERSTAND THE
EMPLOYMENT BARRIERS THAT THEY
FACE.
THE PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE IS THAT
THIS CREATES A PREJUDICIAL
DISTINCTION BETWEEN VARIOUS
PROTECTED CLASSES UNDER THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING ACT.
AND WE KNOW THAT WOMEN AND LGBT
INDIVIDUALS ARE UNDER
REPRESENTED IN THE VETERANS
POPULATION AND THE WHOLE REASON
WHY.
A BILL LIKE THIS IS NECESSARY
WHY WE NEED STATUTORY
AUTHORIZATION IS BECAUSE THERE
IS THIS PRESUMPTION NOT SUCH A
VETERANS PREFERENCE POLICY IS
DISCRIMINATORY.
BECAUSE IT HAS AN ADVERSE IMPACT
ON WOMEN IN LGBT INDIVIDUALS.
SO -- FOR THOSE REASONS WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION.
NOT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU -- FOR
BRINGING FOR THIS BILL IT'S AN
IMPORTANT BILL I I A I RECOGNIZE
THAT I MAY HAVE.
DIFFERENT OPINIONS THAN SOME
THAT WERE STATED STAY BECAUSE I
DO BELIEVE THAT AS SOMEBODY IS
WILLING -- TO TO OFFER UP.
THEIR LIFE IN SERVICE TO THIS
COUNTRY THAT SOMETIMES WE WE
NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW THE LAWS
CAN.
CONTINUE TO ALLOW FOR THEM TO BE
EMPLOYED AFTER THAT SERVICE -- I
DO AT I'M NOT EVEN I I
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'RE DOING AS
FAR AS THE TRANS GENDER BAND I
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S.
BEING DONE AND WHAT'S BEING SAID
EVEN ABOUT.
THE DON'T ASK DON'T TELL HOWEVER
OF COURSE I I KNOW A NUMBER OF
VETERANS WHO SERVED UNDER GOD
MASSIVE TELL THAT THAT WERE IN
FACT A IT WAS UNFORTUNATE THAT
THEY HAD TO HIDE.
BUT THERE THERE ARE NUMBER OF
LGBT Q. -- VETERANS FROM THAT
ERA I DO WANT TO MAKE SURE IF
SOMEBODY WAS DISHONORABLY
DISCHARGED FOR BEING GAY.
IN THE MILITARY THAT THEY WOULD
STILL BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
[inaudible]
THERE [inaudible]
SO YES.
I AM SOMEWHAT EXPERT IS AREA THE
IN A VETERAN.
THIS BILL WAS AMENDED TWO YEARS
AGO -- TO GIVE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
TO THE WHOLE LGBT Q. COMMUNITY.
THE WAY THE MILITARY WORKS IS IN
ORDER TO GET A DISHONORABLE
DISCHARGE YOU HAVE TO BE COURT
MARTIALED.
OKAY AND CONVICTED.
AND THAT'S A BIG DEAL IN THE
MILITARY.
SO. 99% OF GAYS AND I DON'T KNOW
EXACTLY WHAT THE PRESENT IS.
PERCENT IS BUT IT'S GOTTA BE
SOMEWHERE AROUND THERE.
THAT RECEIVED A DISHONORABLE
DISCHARGE LIKE ANY OTHER VETERAN.
COMMITTED CRIMINAL ACTS EXCEPT.
NOW THIS BILL AND IT'S A LITTLE
TRICKY IF YOU'RE NOT MILITARY
[inaudible]
I INCLUDED.
ANYONE THAT WAS DISCHARGE UNDER
HONORABLE CONDITIONS A GENERAL
DISCHARGE NO A GENERAL DISCHARGE
WAS USED BY THE MILITARY FOR
MANY YEARS THE BASICALLY GET RID
OF DON'T ASK DON'T TELL PEOPLE.
SO WHAT THIS BILL DOES IT
RESTORES EQUALITY AND HONOR. TO
THOSE VETERANS AND THEY WILL
HAVE THE SAME PREFERENCES ANYONE
ELSE SO I'M PROUD FROM AN L. G..
VIEW POINT. TO SUPPORT THIS CAN
I GET EMOTIONAL ABOUT IT BECAUSE
IT'S AN INJUSTICE SO WELL
POINTED OUT.
THAT THIS BILL CORRECTS -- SO --
THE OPPOSITION.
I'M ALWAYS CONFUSED I DON'T
THINK THEY REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
POSITIVE IMPACT OF THIS BILL.
AND BECAUSE WE'RE HOLDING IT UP
FOR TRANS GENDER FROM THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION I WELCOME
THAT.
TOO BECAUSE THAT'S FAIR I GET IT
OKAY -- ONE OTHER COMMENT IF I
MAY YES PLEASE [inaudible]
SO. 80%.
THERE ARE SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED VETERANS IN
CALIFORNIA THEY GET OUT OF THE
MILITARY EVERY YEAR.
SO IT'S NOT A LARGE POPULATION
HAS A SMALL POPULATION
[inaudible]
AND 80% MAYBE 78% ARE IN LISTED
PEOPLE THE JOINED UP FOR FOUR
YEARS WENT TO WAR PTSD
EVERYTHING ELSE.
AND THEY HAVE A HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION MAY BE A LITTLE BIT OF
COLLEGE SO THERE'S THREE THINGS
THESE VETERANS HAVE TO DO
OTHERWISE OAKLAND UP HOMELESS
AND SCREWED UP ON YOU.
AND THAT IS ONE GET A JOB. TO GO
TO SCHOOL.
AND THREE STAY OFF THE HARD
DRUGS.
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE MOST
VETERANS INCLUDING ME WILL BE
DRINKERS [inaudible]
OKAY.
AND IT'S THE ONES ARE GOING TO
THE DRUGS THAT SLIDE OFF THE
RAILS.
SO -- IN A CONTROLLED DRINKER A
BITE AT THAT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WHEN THERE'S
NOT PEOPLE I I DON'T WE HAVE
WITNESSED A QUORUM RIGHT NOW
OKAY SO IF WE CAN -- DO WILL
CALL FORM PLEASE MADAM SECRETARY
[inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
LARA [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
DEEP [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
JONES SAWYER PRESENT THREE OF US.
WITHOUT A MOVING NOW
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- AND SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION -- AND THE YOU KNOW AND
THIS I I ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND
AND THE CONCERNS OF THE
OPPOSITION BUT I DO APPRECIATE --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VOEPEL IS I
TRULY BELIEVE YOUR SINCERITY AND
NOT TRYING TO HARM.
ANYONE AT THINK ACCEPTANCE OF
THIS AMENDMENT.
ISN'T WHAT YOU THE MOMENT I
MENTIONED TO YOU WITHIN SECONDS
YOU AGREED TO IT WASN'T
SOMETHING THAT YOU MOLD OVER YOU
UNDERSTOOD THAT -- BUT WITH THE
TRANSGENDER BAN ON ITS FACE THIS
BECOMES.
A BY ITSELF A DISCRIMINATORY
POLICY AND SO WE HAVE TO CLEARLY
ALLOW FOR THAT TO BE LIFTED --
AND ABOUT -- I I UNDERSTAND IT
YOU'RE ABOUT TO BELIEVE IT ALL
THE ONLY VIçT NAM VETERAN.
REMAINING IN THE LEGISLATURE.
SO I KNOW YOUR COMMITMENT TO
VETERANS IS THERE BUT I DO
BELIEVE THAT.
YOU'VE TAKEN A LOT OF TIME IN
YOUR COUPLE YEARS HERE WORKING
VERY CLOSELY WITH SOME WITH --
BUT ALL OF US BUT IT WAS MORE
LGBT Q. -- MEMBERS IN TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BETTER -- HOW YOU CAN
DEVISE A BILL OF THAT IS MORE
FAIR I UNDERSTAND THE OPPOSITION
POSITION JUST BASED ON SHEER
NUMBERS ALONE -- MAKE IT SUCH
THAT -- IT MAY TAKE MANY YEARS --
FOR FOR THE UP OPPOSITION TO
CONSIDER THIS TO BE A TYPE OF
POLICY THAT WOULD BE TRULY A
GLOBAL.
AND SO I UNDERSTAND BOTH SIDES
THEN THERE'S GONNA BE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION ON IT I DO
BELIEVE THAT -- ME YOUR
INTENTIONS ARE ARE CLEAR -- IT
DOES ENJOY AN AYE RECOMMENDATION
IS ALL ALLOW YOU -- TO MAKE ANY
CLOSING REMARKS [inaudible]
PLEASE.
WITH THAT MASSACRE CALL THE ROLL.
QUESTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA
CARILLO [inaudible]
DEEP.
HI DEEP I AND SALAS.
GONZALEZ SIDE JONES SAWYER HI
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US
DOUGLAS ALL RIGHT SO THAT THE
BILL IS OUT AS PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS THANK YOU AS
WELL THANK YOU.
BUT IF WE CAN HAVE A MOTION ON
THE WE HAVE SIX CONSENT ITEMS WE
CAN OF MOTION THOSE.
WILL MOVE.
OKAY -- I'M GOING.
TO SO THE BILLS ON CONSENT --
CONSENT TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AB.
FIVE NINETY FOUR AB.
TEN NINETEEN AB TEN TWENTY EIGHT
A. B. TWELVE NINETY NINE AB.
FIFTEEN FIFTY FOUR AND WE HAVE
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR WHICH IS --
DO PASS CONSENT TO THE FLOOR.
OKAY KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA
CREO.
DEEP BY DEEP AYE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER BY JONES
SAWYER I THREE OF US -- RAY
CONSENT CALENDAR IS OUT -- WE
HAVE MR LE VIAN.
HERE ON ITEM EIGHT IS THAT RIGHT
AND WHAT IS YEP THIS WILL BE IN
PLEASE.
ITEM [inaudible]
EIGHT THAT IS.
AB SEVEN NINETY AND AS I
INDICATED PREVIOUSLY IF YOU DO
HAVE WITNESSES HAVE UP TO SIX
MINUTES ON EITHER SIDE PLEASE
FANTASTIC THANK YOU SO MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY WOULD REQUIRE COMPANIES
OPERATING IN CALIFORNIA BY.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER THAT HAVE A MARKET
VALUATION OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS TO PAY SUBCONTRACTED
SERVICE WORKERS WAGES THAT ARE
TIED TO CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
HOUSING.
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT'S INCOME LEVELS FOR
THE COUNTY THEY ARE
SUBCONTRACTED TO WORK IN THESE
COMPANIES SHALL BE REQUIRED TO
PAY A WAGE TO CONTRACTED SERVICE
WORKERS THAT.
IF PAID FOR EIGHT EIGHT HOUR
WORK DAY OVER A FORTY HOUR WORK
WEEK WOULD EQUAL AN ANNUAL WAGE
THAT IS 85% OF H. CD'S AREA
MEDIAN INCOME.
MAJOR CORPORATIONS ARE MAKING
THE BIGGEST PROFITS IN HISTORY
AND ARE NOW RECEIVING
SIGNIFICANT CORPORATE TAX CUTS
INITIATED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP.
IN ADDITION CORPORATIONS ARE
INCREASINGLY CONTRACTING OUT
SERVICE LABOR LEAVING THESE
WORKERS WITHOUT AN EMPLOYEE
TITLE THESE WORKERS INCLUDE
STAFF SUCH AS SECURITY GUARDS
BUS DRIVERS CUSTODIAL STAFF FOOD
SERVICE WORKERS.
LAUNDRY WORKERS WINDOW CLEANERS
AND OTHERS.
DUE TO THIS CLASSIFICATION AS A
CONTRACTED OR SUBCONTRACTED
WORKER THESE WORKERS ARE ALMOST
ALWAYS NOT RECEIVING THE HIGHER
WAGES THAT REGULAR EMPLOYEES
GENERALLY RECEIVE FOR THE VERY
SAME WORK.
THE FAIR WAGES REQUIRED BY THIS
BILL WILL HELP CLOSE THE UPWARD
MOBILITY AND INCOME INEQUALITY
GAPS THANK YOU AND I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANYONE OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY MY
NAME'S LAURA CURTIS I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE.
WE ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO AB
SEVEN NINETY BECAUSE WE FEEL IT
WILL ARTIFICIALLY INCREASE THE
COST FOR THESE TYPES OF SERVICES --
WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE BILLS
WELL INTENTIONED HOWEVER IF YOU
LOOK AT THE COST OF THE AREA
MEDIAN INCOME WHICH TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT.
MANY PROFESSIONS SUCH AS DOCTORS
LAWYERS ARCHITECTS AS WELL AS
LOWER WAGE WORKERS I'M IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY THAT'S EIGHTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR IF
YOU'RE LOOKING 85% OF THAT THAT
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR.
THIS IS A VERY HIGH COST WE ARE
AFRAID THAT THIS WILL IN
ADDITION TO ARTIFICIALLY --
DRIVING UP THE COST OF THESE
SERVICES IT WILL ALSO ELIMINATE
JOBS FOR INDIVIDUALS THAT
CURRENTLY HAVE THESE JOBS ON A
CONTRACT BASIS.
BECAUSE MORE COMPANIES WILL HIRE
THESE PEOPLE IN HOUSE IN ORDER
TO TO A MULTITUDE OF DIFFERENT --
TASKS RATHER THAN HIRING EACH
ONE INDIVIDUALLY ADDITIONALLY WE
ARE WORRIED ABOUT THE COMPLIANCE
BECAUSE IT REQUIRES THAT IF A
COMPANY IS VALUED AT A BILLION
DOLLARS.
THEN THEY HAVE TO PROVIDE THIS
COST -- AND IF THE VALUATION
GOES UP OR DOWN IT'S UNCLEAR HOW
THE EMPLOYER IS GOING TO COMPLY
WITH THE CONTRACT FOR THIS.
ADDITIONALLY THEY WILL BE IN
BREACH OF CONTRACT LET'S SAY IF
THE EMPLOYEE MAYBE WORKS THIRTY
FIVE HOURS THAT WEEK RATHER THAN
A FULL FORTY THESE ARE CONTRACT
INTO -- WORKERS WHO THE EMPLOYER
DON'T IS NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
KEEPING TAP A TRACK OF EVERY
HOUR EVERY MINUTE THAT THEY WORK.
AND WE'RE CONCERNED THAT THEY
WILL BE IN VIOLATION OF THE
CONTRACT IF IT INDIVIDUAL WORKS
MORE OR LESS FOR THESE REASONS
WE ARE OPPOSED AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR IN HIS OFFICE.
AT TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THEY WANT US IN OPPOSITION.
THE CALL RIGHT CALIFORNIA MANY
FACTORS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ALSO POSE FOR THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
I BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
THE MOTION.
AND IS THERE ANY MOTION ON THIS.
HE IS OUR SECOND.
ALL RIGHT UP THANK YOU MISS
LEVINE I THINK IS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION TO HAVE AND I
APPRECIATE THE FACT OPPOSITION --
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT THESE ISSUES
I THINK THAT WE MEAN BEING AND
SILICON VALLEY -- ACTUALLY
RECOGNIZED INCOME INEQUALITY
THAT'S OCCURRING ACTUALLY
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT -- THEY'RE
PROBABLY A LOT OF DIFFERENT
ANGLES TO APPROACH THIS ISSUE
AND I THINK THAT THE
CONVERSATION HOPEFULLY -- WILL
HELP ILLUMINATE DIFFERENT
OPPORTUNITIES WE HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER WITH OUR EMPLOYERS WITH
LABOR -- AND WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES TO ENSURE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE IN THE
DIRECTION TOWARDS COMBATING
INCOME INEQUALITY SO. FOR THE
FOR THOSE REASONS I DOES ENJOY
AND I RECOMMENDATION -- AND YOU
MAY CLOSE.
YET THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
STAFF HAVE BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY
HELPFUL AND AND CRAFTING THIS
LEGISLATION.
I WAS REALLY.
HEARTENED TO HEAR SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS ABOUT
POSSIBLY MAKING MORE EMPLOYEES
OUT OF THEIR CONTRACTED WORKERS
WERE THEY MAY BE ABLE TO GET
BETTER BENEFITS AND HIGHER WAGES.
THE APPROACH THAT THIS BILL
TAKES RECOGNIZES THAT IN IN YOUR
DISTRICT AS WELL AS MINE MANY OF
OUR DISTRICTS THE AVERAGE RENT
OF AN APARTMENT IS APPROACH IS
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A
MONTH.
AT FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN HOUR WHEN
WE GET THERE THAT IS THE WHOLE
PAYCHECK FOR THE MONTH THERE IS
NO WAY. TO HAVE A SECURE FUTURE
OR TO GET BY WITHOUT SINKING
DEEPER AND DEEPER INTO DEBT --
FOR SO MANY HARD WORKING
FAMILIES AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP IN HELPING
ADVANCES TODAY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
A BAND CENTRIC POLO PLEASE.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA CREEL.
DEEP NO DEEP NO GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US.
SO PLACE AT THE BILL ON CALL
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MISS GONZALEZ.
ASSEMBLY IS ALSO ITEM.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE FORTY SEVEN YOU
READY TO GO.
A LOT OF PEOPLE I THINK --
INTEREST IN THIS.
ONE SO WE HAVE UP NEXT AB.
FIVE FORTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ.
AND AS NOTED PREVIOUSLY UP TO
SIX MINUTES FOR EACH SIDE -- CAN
BREAK IT UP ANYWAY YOU'D LIKE.
AND I DO NOT HOLD THE TIME FOR
IT IF THERE IS ANY TRANSLATING
SORRY I DON'T KNOW THAT TIME
AGAINST.
JUST A PROCEDURAL QUESTION WE
ARE ACTUALLY DEBATING THIS -- I
THINK MOST MEMBER SPEAKS SPANISH
WOULD YOU LIKE A TRANSLATION DO
WE HAVE TO HAVE A TRANSLATION
IT'S REALLY UP.
TO I WOULD PREFER TRANSLATE OKAY
THE RECORD JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
[inaudible]
I AM.
WE HAVE A TRANSLATOR.
I DO MY TRANSLATION -- THANK YOU
I JUST WANT TO CHECK ON THAT.
AT GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR -- IN
WELCOME WHAT AN APPROPRIATE DATE
TODAY TO BE HEARING THIS BILL --
IT'S DENIM DAY AND OF COURSE WE
TALK ABOUT A SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
THIS BILL REALLY CAME OUT OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT IN THE WORKPLACE
SOMETHING THAT WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON WITH OUR JANITORIAL
SECTOR FOR MANY YEARS NOW.
AND BEFORE THE ME TOO MOVEMENT
CAME ALONG OF COURSE THERE WAS
THE OUT BASKET MOVEMENT --
STARTED BY THESE REALLY BRAVE --
WOMEN WHO SERVE IN A JANITORIAL
SECTOR TO SAY THAT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT AND RAPE
ON THE JOB WAS NOT OKAY -- WE
HAD AN INITIAL BILL THAT CREATED
REGISTRY AND PROVIDED FOR
TRAINING AND AS WE ARE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THAT BILL WE
REALIZE THAT THE TRAINING -- THE
JANITORS CANON SHOULD RECEIVE
WOULD BE MOST APPROPRIATE TO
COME FROM THEIR PEERS FROM OTHER
JANITORS TO HAVE AN ATTORNEY
COME IN AND TEACH.
ON JENNER'S WITHOUT THE THEIR
LANGUAGE WITHOUT THEIR CULTURE
ABOUT HOW -- TO PREVENT TO
UNDERSTAND THEIR THERE WERE LAWS
HOW TO PREVENT SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND ASSAULT REALLY DOESN'T MATCH
UP WITH THE EXPECTATIONS OF OUR
JANITORS.
SO THEY CAME BACK WITH ANOTHER
BILL LAST YEAR TO TRY TO ENSURE
THAT THE TRAINING COULD BE DONE
BY -- PROMOTE TOLD US OUR PEER
REVIEWERS THEMSELVES -- IT'S A
GREAT DEAL UNFORTUNATELY -- OUR
LAST GOVERNOR IN HIS A SPLASH OF
SIGNING ME TO BILLS SEEM TO LEFT
OUT ALL WORKING CLASS WOMEN.
AND THIS WAS ONE OF OUR MANY
VETOES THAT WE GOT SO WE'RE BACK
WITH IT BECAUSE IF THERE'S ONE
THING YOU CAN LEARN FROM OUR OUR
JANITORS IS THEY ARE UNWILLING
TO STOP AT A NOW -- SO WITH THAT
I HAVE.
I HAVE FOLKS HERE READY TO
TESTIFY AND TRANSLATE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI A GOOD AFTERNOON I'D LIKE TO
THANK THIS COMMITTEE ENTER KALRA
FOR ALLOWING ME TO TESTIFY
BEFORE YOU -- MY NAME IS CENTER
AND RE GUESTS AND I'M THE CEO OF
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION AGAINST
SEXUAL ASSAULT APPRECIATE THOSE
OF YOU CAME OUT TODAY FOR DENIM
DAY AND WEARING.
JEANS TODAY.
AND I'M HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF FIVE FORTY SEVEN THE
JANITORIAL WORKERS SEXUAL
VIOLENCE AND HARASSMENT
PREVENTION TRAINING BILL. FOR
DECADES SEXUAL ASSAULT VICTIMS
OR SURVIVORS AS OUR PREFERRED
TERM HAVE BEEN RISING UP TO SAY
ENOUGH. TO SAY WE DO NOT ACCEPT
ABUSE AS INEVITABLE IN OUR LIVES.
THIS BILL IS THE SPIRIT BY WITH
EACH THE ANTI VIOLENCE AGAINST
WOMEN MOVEMENT WAS BUILT
BEGINNING IN THE EARLY SEVENTIES.
THE MOVEMENT HAS ACCOMPLISHED A
LOT BUILDING A STATEWIDE SAFETY
NET DEDICATED TO LIMITING SEXUAL
ABUSE AND ELEVATING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT.
MISCONDUCT AND ABUSE.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR EFFORTS IN THE
PAST FORTY EIGHT YEARS
OVERLOOKED CERTAIN COMMUNITIES.
MUCH LIKE ANTI RAPE ADVOCATES
DID IN THE SEVENTIES.
TODAY MANY OF THESE COMMUNITIES
ARERISING UP ALSO TO SAY ENOUGH.
BASTA.
WE CANNOT WAIT ANY LONGER.
WE WILL TAKE HEALING TRAINING
AND PREVENTION EFFORTS INTO OUR
OWN HANDS.
CALIFORNIA'S JANITORS ARE ONE
SUCH GROUP.
THEY ARE A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO HAVE HAD THE COURAGE TO COME
FORWARD AND EDUCATE MANY OF US
ABOUT THEIR EXPERIENCES IN THE
WORKPLACE.
THEY HAVE ALSO SPENT THE LAST
THREE AND A HALF YEARS BECOMING
EXPERTS IN THE DRESSING AND
PREVENTING SEXUAL HARASSMENT
MISCONDUCT AND ABUSE ON THE
NIGHT SHIFT.
I AM HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT A. B.
FIVE FORTY SEVEN WHICH WOULD
RECOGNIZE THESE WORKERS AS
EXPERTS.
NOT ONLY IN THEIR LIVED
EXPERIENCE AS JACK AS JANITORS
BUT ALSO SO UNIQUELY SUITED TO
BE PEER TRAINERS WHO DELIVER THE
IN PERSON SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
AND HARASSMENT PREVENTION
TRAINING TO EMPLOYERS AND
COVERED WORKERS.
AB FIVE FORTY SEVEN CALLS FOR
PEER TRAINERS TO COMPLETE A
MINIMUM FORTY HOURS ON THE
VARIOUS ASPECTS.
OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ABUSE
TO DATE.
MY ORGANIZATION THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION AGAINST SEXUAL ASSAULT
HAS TRAINED WELL OVER A HUNDRED
WORKERS TO DELIVER THIS PEER
TRAINING.
ADDITIONALLY EACH SUCH TRAINER
WILL RECEIVE A MINIMUM OF TEN
HOURS OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT TRAINING EACH YEAR
AS WELL AS MEET ALL OF THE
REQUIREMENTS OUTLINED IN THIS
BILL -- CALCOT SAYS.
OR A SURE THAT EACH OF THE
TRAINED PEER.
TRAINERS AND EDUCATORS RECEIVE
TRAINING WHICH COVERS THE
CONTENT AND MEETS THE STANDARDS
OF THE STATE CERTIFIED TRAINING.
THAT ALSO RECEIVED -- BY THOSE
WORKING ON BEHALF OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT VICTIMS IT'S THE SAME
TRAINING WHICH RAPE CRISIS
ADVOCATES WHO HAVE COMPLETED
WOULD HAVE COMPLETED FOR THE
LAST THIRTY WE YEARS.
BY WHICH THEY HAVE BECOME
QUALIFIED AS PEER ADVOCATES AND
TRAINERS.
IN THE ANTI SEXUAL VIOLENCE
MOVEMENT WE KNOW THAT PEER
EMPOWERMENT AND TRAINING MODELS
WORK.
CALIFORNIA NOT LAW ALSO
RECOGNIZES THE VALUE OF THESE
MODELS.
PEER MODELS WORK BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT THOSE AFFECTED BY
SEXUAL VIOLENCE ARE EXPERTS IN
THEIR OWN LIVES.
AND AS SUCH ARE THE BEST SUITED
TO DEVELOP VICTIM CENTERED
STRATEGIES.
PIERRE TRAINING FACILITATES THE
DISSEMINATION OF INFORMATION
BECAUSE TRAINERS ARE OFTEN SEEN
AS BEING APPROACHABLE AND ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR HAVING WALKED IN.
OTHER ISSUES.
EDUCATION HAS ALSO BEEN SHOWN TO
BE MORE EFFECTIVE THAN OTHER
TYPES OF ADULT LEGIT EDUCATION
IN TERMS OF CHANGING BEHAVIORS
ATTITUDES AND NORMS.
JANITORS KNOW BEST THE WAYS IN
WHICH UP SEXUAL HARASSMENT
MISCONDUCT AND ABUSE PLAY OUT IN
THEIR INDUSTRY.
RECOGNIZING THEM AS PURE
TRAINERS WOULD HELP TO BUILD
STRENGTH IN THE LABOR MOVEMENT
[inaudible]
FIND STRENGTH.
AND AGENCY WHEN THEY CAN BE A
PART OF THE SOLUTION TO THEIR
OWN PLIGHT.
TODAY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD.
IN BUILDING WORKER CENTERED
SOLUTIONS YOUR VOTE HERE TODAY --
PROVIDES THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CATALYZE A TRANSFORMATION IN THE
JANITORIAL INDUSTRY AND BY
EXTENSION OTHER INDUSTRIES WHO
CAN ALSO ADOPT SIMILAR PEER
MODELS.
SEXUAL ABUSE IS NOT INEVITABLE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THAT QUITE
A BIT THIS MORNING.
IT CAN BE PREVENTED AND I ASK
THIS COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
GENDERS AND BEING PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO AND ABUSE WITHIN
THEIR INDUSTRY BY MOVING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND I ASK FOR YOUR
A BOAT.
THANK YOU ABOUT TWO MINUTES
REMAINING -- AND AGAIN THE
TRANSITION WILL BE HELD AGAINST
THE PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN.
OKAY -- MY EVEN A STATUS
PRESIDENT THAT KARA E. HONORARY
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE.
NUMBER IS GOING TO HIT ON YOU
MIGHT THE BOTTOM AS A ONE OF A
KIND ITEM HAD AND JUST DIDN'T
GET THAT.
I SEE IN THE WAY SOME OF THE
PIECES MY HORSES LOS ANGELES
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN KALRA
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS ERICA HEAT ON AND
FORMER THAT COULD HAVE WORK IN
THE DENTAL INDUSTRY CLEANING THE
MOST LUXURIOUS BUILDINGS IN THE
CITY OF LA.
ISN'T THAT A HOLDING UP IN A YOU
KNOW THAT BELIEVE US GOT A NOTE
TO ME IS THAT HIS COMPANY AS A
COMPANION TO THAT OF A WHOLE ANY
SEMBLANCE OF SOLICITING
DISABILITY BESTSELLER LEVEL YET
TO THE CALIFORNIA.
IN WHICH HAS A QUESTION IS THAT --
HOW MUCH SO AS I MAY LOSE ING IF
HE'S A COMPLETE THEM INTO THE
CIRCLE BY THE THE THIS IS THE
BEST SELLING THAT WHENEVER?
WHENEVER THE THAT MOTOR VEHICLE
BY UNESCO BY YOU KNOW SENSITIVE
SEE THE VICTIM AT VICTIMIZED
ACOSTA X. ZERO SIX ONE IT IS A
DIGNIFIED JOB BUT FULL OF DANGER.
EVERY NIGHT THOUSANDS OF MY
COWORKERS STARTER NIGHT SHIFT.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
A LOT OF TIMES WE WORK ALONE
WITH HIM LIGHTS IN COMPLETELY
EMPTY BUILDINGS AND TO THE OWNER
AVAILITY MANY OF MY COWORKERS
HAVE BEEN VICTIMS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL ASSAULT.
IN THE MID TEENS SO IN THE
COMMENT THAT A PREVIOUS THE
HAULING AB THAN CYNICAL BUT GAME
BUT THEN OF COURSE US SO SO TO
BE INTO THAT YOU'RE INTO SIX ONE
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN A PBS
DOCUMENTARY.
CHAU SHOP SHOWED CHINA LIGHT ON
THE VIOLENCE.
THE CULTURE OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE
AT THE WORKPLACE.
A YEAR LATER IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
WE SUPPORT AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT SPONSORED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ FOR STATUS OF
REGISTRY OF WORKERS IN THE
INDUSTRY.
AS WELL AS TO PROMOTE THE
TRAINING TO PREVENT SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND SEXUAL VIOLENCE AT
THE WORKPLACE WELL THEN YOU MUST
COME ALSO TO BE INVISIBLE THAT I
THINK ABOUT THE STATUS YOU GONNA
COME BECAUSE ON THE COMBAT LUCK
WITH THAT THANKS TO GOD GIVE HIM
THAT ELEMENT.
CAñADA ELEMENT THAT BY THAT
LIMIT THE VIOLENCE THAT IS SIX
ONE TODAY WE COME BEFORE YOU ARE
SURVIVORS.
THE ONLY A SURVIVORS BUT WE'RE
NOT TRAINED AND COMMITTED TO AND
THE THE THE TOXIC CULTURE THAT
PROMOTES SEXUAL ASSAULT IN THE
WORKPLACE.
I WOULD AND THIS IS THE THE MOST
OF MY APPROACH HIM A BI SYLLABIC
SINGLE WHEN THEY SEE IT THERE
THE ASSEMBLY SOMEONE SALAS KNOWS
BUT ANYTHING IS SET UP AUTOMATIC
FROM WHAT THE WHAT I SCAN THOSE
THAT ADOLESCENT I MEAN THAT'S
THE LOOK UP I SEE THE SOON.
AS THE SETUP BUT A BUT THE
HIPNESS IF THE CAPACITY THE
SENATE BY MAIS THAT YET MATT BY
MY SIDE ON THIS ISSUE IN THE
CLASSES.
IF THAT'S THE BUT THE THE
SOONEST I YOU LAUGH WHAT BELLA
SILONE THEY LOVE WHAT I I
BIGELOW MESSING BUT THEN THEY
ARE YOU AT APPLE NEARLY I
THOUGHT I'D GO SEE IT OF IT IS A
SIX BUT IN A SINGLE SITTING.
BUT NOW WE WE MUST THINK THE
NEXT STEP AND THE NEXT STEP IS
SUPPORTING AB FIVE FORTY SEVEN
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
WHICH WILL ALLOW US.
TO CREATE A PROGRAM OF PEER
TRAINERS TO GIVE US THE TOOLS
AND TRAINING NECESSARY TO
PROTECT THIS THESE TRAINEES ARE
MORE THAN JUST CLASSES THESE ARE
TWENTY THAT WILL STRENGTHEN
WORKER UNITY.
WILL STRENGTHEN THE ABILITY FOR
SURVIVORS TO HEAL THEIR WOUNDS
EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY IT WOULD HELP WITH
SPRINT AND SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN OUR INDUSTRY.
DICIEMBRE THE CALIFORNIA BONELLI
HIM FOR THE LAST IN A SORT OF
HAZARDOUS THING YOU PUT THAT IN
WITHIN A FEW MINUTES NATIONALLY
THAT MISTER YOUNG AND IF YOU
MAKE EVERY DAY MOST MISTER
HANOVER IN THE SENSE EXCITED
[inaudible]
SS.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
AND IF SO JUST WE HAD THIS
MICROPHONE TO MY LEFT HERE.
AND JUST LINE UP IN A BRIDGES
HAVE.
OF YOUR NAME.
ANY PARTICULAR ORGANIZATION.
YOUR AFFILIATE WITH.
AND YOUR SUPPORT POSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
ARE NAY BAYARDO S. YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA RESPONSE OR THE BILL --
AS FOR SUPPORT OKAY.
YEAH YEAH YEAH.
THE NUMBER IS SOME OF A LACKEY
TODAY EAT THEM YEAH BE THOUGH A
LOT FOR YOUR BUT ALLOW THE
SINGLE ONE AND I SEE AT THE JOB
I STOP.
CRISIS NUMBER IS LOTUS
THOUGHTLESSLY UP ALL YOUR LIFE.
W. O. YEAH LAST ON THE TENTH OF
YOUR LAZY I LOOKED UP.
AS WE NUMBER SEVEN HUNDRED RPM
NOT BY SOCIAL RE INTERVIEW
LANCIA.
YOUR BILL UP WHERE PRESS A
PROGRAMMER FOR PROBLEMS
[inaudible]
AS MY NAME IS MY IS HELPING ON
SUPPORT THE THE BURKE BY THE
LEYVA AB FIVE FORTY SEVEN AND I
SAY THE OF US THAT.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE IT CAMINO
THE MICROPHONE TO THE CENTER.
AND IF EVERYBODY CAN A YEAH
RATHER THAN HAVING EVERYONE
SQUEEZE INTO THAT LITTLE SPOT
WILL MOVE TO THE CENTER AND THEN.
PEOPLE TO RE ORIENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU -- NUMBER OF MONEY ASK
WHEN THEY YEP WILLIAMS AND I LAY
AVENUES SINGLE WHEN THEY SEE THE
PROCESS.
WE NOTICED MY DNA YOUR BILL UP
FOR YOU BUT I LOVE PROPOSED TO
SOON AVE SINGLE POINT AND THEY
SEE IF THE FINANCES LAY YEAH
LAST THAT.
ME NUMBERS OF HIS CAMINO SORRY
GET OKAY TO SUPPORT HIM BUT ALAS.
LATE BUT I YOU KNOW MY GOODNESS
YEAH MUST BE LESS AND LESS OKAY
IT IS HE GONNA RESPECT IS A
LITTLE LESS IS LESS.
MINIMALIST BUT ALSO GET ESE
DUMMY THE STAY UP OR DOWN THE
THOUGHT SLA BUT I THE CITY OF
AUSTIN OPULENCE.
CRISIS LAST.
WHEN IS THAT THEY MAY NUMBER
MANY AT ONCE AYE LYSIAS THE EKIE
PRODUCT IS THERE IS NO SIMPLE
YOU IMPORT FOR WATER?
I LATE AVE YOU NEED TO PUT IN
PLACE YET BIG BASS YES.
NUMBER OF MONEY -- MAGELLAN BUT
THAT AS SCHOOL USE THE EXAMPLE
YOUNG LADY OF US THAT LOOK AT
THAT OF WINNING.
THAT'S THE PROCESS.
WHEN I FOUND THAT MY NUMBER IS
BLOODY ABOUT I'M I'M SO YOU'RE
NOT A LARGE ANY TALK OF ANIMAL
SUPPLE YET LATELY?
SINGLE QUOTE IN PLACE YET THAT
WILL MEAN THE MENTALIST BUT THE
MOST OF HOW WATER CAN ALSO
YOU'LL THEM BUT I COULD PROCESS
THOUGHT LES IT'LL BE THE OPEN SO
THEN I JANET THOUGHT THAT THE
LITTLE CALIFORNIA GRASS YES.
AND WHEN I SEVEN MINIMALISM
LOCUSTS.
MINGLE IF A VEHICLE BY FOR YET
AND I BE SINGLE COURT AND BASS
YET THE IT'S BEEN.
MOST LIKELY MISTER SORREL
CONDOLENCE HAVE BUT I'M ALSO
THROWS BONUS BECAUSE WE GRAY
MOST OF THE PEOPLE OF PROGRAM.
GOD HAS BLESSED US.
THE NUMBER IS ONE WITH A GAL
EVEN UP WE ALLOW A BIG LAUGH
THINK OF WHAT AND THEY SEE IT
THEY SINCE.
WHEN I STARTED THIS NUMBER IS
OUR COMPANY LIKE IT WAS?
SO GENTLE MAN WITH A SINGLE SET.
AND IT WAS UP WE ANALYZE
COMPANIONS GENITALS.
NOT A CALIFORNIA THE THIRD
PARTIES.
I LOVE COMPANION OF PROMOTERS
BUT A BECAUSE IT WAS BUT THIS IS
RIDICULOUS BACK IN THE SOMEONE
THAT I'M LIST.
YOU BETTER GET THE PAULA CLOSE.
BELOW THE SILICON LOCAL
NEWSPAPER I CEREMONIES BECAUSE
IF THAT'S WHEN I FIVE IS MY
NUMBER IS BLANK I GALA. FOR
JANITORIAL TO LOAD ON A CHAIR --
WILL MOVE INTO THE CHORE -- LAST
PERSONAS GET THERE ABOUT HOW
MORE THAN OR JUST SOMEONE
MUGGLENET OBVIOUS.
ESTAMOS SOLAS -- WHICH OF THIS
IN MY SO WHAT DO THAT.
SO IN THOSE AS PORTABLE AS BY
THE MOST ON A BILLION THAT AT
NOT A SINGLE FORTRESS YET THEM.
I KNOW FOR I THOUGHT IT WAS OF A
SENATE BILL UP WE HAVE A NAY
YEAH ACOSTA [inaudible]
CRISIS.
WHEN I STARTED THIS ME NUMBERS
HE'S ACCENTURE'S SO YEAH ANY
THOUGHT YOUR FOR YOUR LATE A. B.?
YOU NEED TO PUT IN PLACE YET THE
CLASSES.
WE WANNA START THE NUMBER OF
MINUTES THAT THEY GOT TO SEE A
COMPLETE THESE A SIGN OF THEIR
THEM.
SO JENNIFER AN INTERNAL J. LEFT
IT OPEN FOR WATER NO SIMPLE
YOUNG ACTORS SAY I GOT A LATE
ADVANCED SINGLE QUITE AND THEY
SEE THAT THE DRESS YES CLASS.
MEAN NUMBER IS BLANK OUTLANDER'S
PRABHAKARAN OPENED YOU GET A
COUPLE MORE WARM THIS UP FOR YOU
IN THE LATE I HAVE A SINGLE
POINT IN PLACE YET.
GLASS YES CLASSES.
THE NUMBER OF MY TRAVIS THE
STORY BUT A NUMBER BUT AS A
PROMOTER.
YOUR FOR THE MEN DOUBLE YOUR LA
I HAVE A GETTING DISCORDANT THEY
SEE IT THEY GET A MUST BUY LOCAL
TO THE THE APPLE SALINAS TJ BASS.
CLASSIC LESS.
WHEN I STOP THIS ME NUMBER SALAS
HIS SPOT?
IS THE MOST LACKEY PRODUCT IN
THE BOTTOM OF ONE OF THE FOUR
YOUNG MOST CANNELLA.
LAKE.
AVE WHEN SINGLE POINT THEY SEE
IT THEY GET OFFICE PRESS.
WHEN I STATUS NUMBER THIRTY COME
ALONE IS TO YANKEE UP AGAIN THE
LATE ABBY THINK OF THAT I CAN
ASSEMBLY AND WHEN THE LADY
COMMUTERS WHEN THEY SEE?
US. ONE OF THE NUMBER OF A CAN'T
EVEN THOUGH THE SUNDAY LIVING UP
TO THE LIST AS A RIGOROUS THE
PROPONENTS OF FOR YOU AND THEN
THE PROPOSED SINGLE BUT IF THEY
SEE IF I CAN ASSIST.
US.
HELLO ME A MOMENT LET ME THE
MAPLE WOOD UP WE AND LOUDLY
CAPACITOR LAKE YOU ARE MAKING IT
LOOK LIKE THIS AT THE CLASS YES.
UNDERSTANDTHIS MINIMUM AUDIO
EVEN UP WE ALLOW LATE OF IT CAN
IT'S GOING TO SIT THERE.
WE WERE THE STATUS OF THOSE WE
NUMBER THE STARS HE TO KNOWING
WHEN IDEA CONTRA COSTA.
EVEN WHAT THE LEAD THE FOUR K.
L. YOU THE MOST UP OUTSIDE IS
THAT LADY.
IS SINGLE QUINTAS HIT THEIR
THEIR COASTAL SIX WELL BUT I KEY
I WATCHED.
LAST.
WHEN I SEVENTY NUMBERS BUT A
HUMANITY SAVING UP WITH LA YEAH
BUSCA?
YES -- ME NUMBER ELEVEN BUT I'M
ALSO DOWNIEVILLE THAN OJ THE
WHOLE THING WE YOUR AVAILABLE I
BELIEVE. FOR FIVE WORKABLE YEAH
LAKE YOU NEED DISCARDED THANK
FOR GUARDIANS THEY SEE IT THE
REST.
CLASSES.
WHEN THE NUMBER HERE ILLEGALLY
YES THEY ARE HE PAID -- UP WE
HAD A MEETING UP WE ALLOW UP
WITH WAS THE SEAL OF AC WHAT IT
IS CLASSES.
MY NAME IS WILL FILE THE AYE
ORGANIZED JANITORS IN THE EAST
BAY I'M HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE FORTY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THE NUMBER THE NICKEL IS SO YOU
DON'T EVEN.
AVAILABLE -- IN SINGLE WHAT IT
IS A MOVE IN GENESIS.
CLASSES.
WHEN I STARTED EMINEM RECORD
LOWS MAN THIS THING MOVING TO
NINE YOU'RE HERE SUPPORT THE LIE
I?
BASED SINGLE PUT INTO SAID.
BUT IS THAT IT IS ME NUMBERS MAY
NOT EAT THEM BEING AT THE APPLE
YANDEL IVY THINK WHAT IF THEY
SEE IT THE PROCESS.
WHEN A STATE MINIMUM IDEA SAID
RANDALL YOU STAY UP WAY AND A
LOT OF A SINGLE QUIT AND THEY
SAID PLUS?
WHAT DOES THAT IS THE NUMBER IS
HAS THOSE VALUES?
HELLO MY NAME IS SAM X. TO STAND
UP PROUD DAUGHTER OF A JANITOR
AND ALSO A SURVIVOR OF RAPE
SURVIVOR IN THE NIGHT SHIFT
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH AND
THAT IF THEY WORK WITH
GENERATORS -- SURVIVORS AND VERY
COURAGEOUS -- WOMEN AND I
SUPPORT AB FIVE FORTY SEVEN
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHORE TRYING
MANAGING ATTORNEY WORK SAFE AND
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SEND IDEAS VICE
PRESIDENT WITH SCA U. S. W. W.
AND OF COURSE FOR HIS SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU.
HI MISTER CHAIR CAITLYN VEGA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THESE
WOMEN AND OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED SAID VAN RECESS
OUT OF THE OTHER CONCEALERS THAT
THE ELOQUENCE TOO SOON YOU KNOW
WE'LL UP WE ARE LATE YEAH BUT?
THAT'S YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE
MEGAN SUPERS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
VERY GOOD YES HARM TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA WOMEN LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MATT BROUGHT FOR THE TEAMSTERS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FOR THE REST PERSONAS IN A BOIL.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MORE CURTIS
HERE FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY WE
ARE SYMPATHETIC TO THE ISSUE AT
HAND -- WITH REGARD TO SEXUAL
HARASSMENT SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
VIOLENCE AND CAL CHAMBER AND ITS
MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY -- DO NOT
SUPPORT ANY TYPE OF ACTS OF
VIOLENCE LIKE THAT OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL ARE WITHIN THE
NUANCES -- BUT WE ARE UNDER THE
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER IS COMING OUT WITH
REGULATIONS SPECIFICALLY ON THIS
TOPIC AND WE DO AGREE WITH THE
PREVIOUS VETO MESSAGE IN THAT WE
SHOULD ALLOW FOR THE TIME FOR
THOSE REGULATIONS TO COME OUT
AND THEN DETERMINE WHETHER OR
NOT CHANGES NEED TO BE.
MADE ADDITIONALLY OUR CONCERNS
WITH THIS BILL -- DEAL WITH THE
FACT THAT THE THE CURRENT
VERSION ATTEMPTED TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THE ADDITIONAL
DUPLICATIVE -- NATURE OF
ADDITIONAL TRAINING HOWEVER IN
SUBDIVISION SIX D. IT STILL SAYS
THAT SOMEONE NEEDS TO BE HIRED
IN ADDITION TO THAT -- SEXUAL
HARASSMENT TRAINER THAT IS
PROVIDED WITH REGARD TO THE
GOVERNMENT CODE REGULATIONS THAT
WOULD MEAN YOU HAVE TO HIRE
APPEAR TRAINER IN ADDITION.
TO THE OUR GOVERNMENT CO TRAINER
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE CONCERNS
ADDITIONALLY THE STATUTORY
MANDATE WITH REGARD TO PAY AND
THEN THAT THE LIST OF ENTITIES
THAT COULD PROVIDE THIS TRAINING
CONTROL THE MARKET PLACE.
AND SO OUR CONCERN IS IS THAT
THEY WOULD ADD ONS UNNECESSARILY
DRIVE UP THE COST FOR THIS TYPE
OF TRAINING AND CONTROL WHO CAN
PROVIDE THE TRAINING CURRENTLY
UNDER THE GOVERNMENT CODE AS
LONG AS YOU ARE QUALIFIED
TRAINER.
YOU MAY PROVIDE THE TRAINING WE
THINK THAT THAT'S A BETTER --
ASSESSMENT IF YOU ARE QUALIFIED
AND CAN MEET THOSE STANDARDS AND
YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO TRAIN
RATHER THAN TO HIRING OFF THE
LIST OF FOR THE FOR THE THOSE
ARE OUR CONCERNS AS OF NOW AND
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND
WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
NOT MOBILE BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT -- I'D BE HAPPY TO
MAKE A MOTION IN SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL.
SECOND WE'LL MOTION ON THE FLOOR --
AND I WANT TO THANK US ORGANS
ALSO ONCE AGAIN -- BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD -- I WANT TO THANK
THE WITNESSES THAT -- AT BOTH
THE WITNESSES AS WELL AS THOSE I
SPOKE IN SUPPORT -- YOU KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TENSION ATTENTION THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS AND RIGHTFULLY SO
THE ME TOO MOVEMENT.
THAT HAS HAD SOME OF THE THE
ATTENTION OF HOLLYWOOD.
IN LEGISLATIVE HALLS LEGISLATURE
IN CORPORATE AMERICA BUT I WANT
TO COMMEND THESE JENNER'S THAT
BEFORE THE ME TO MOVE AND WE'RE
RAISING ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE --
AND YOU KNOW I'VE I'VE REMEMBER
WATCHING RAPE ON THE NIGHT SHIFT
WHEN IT FIRST CAME OUT.
AND I THINK THE COURAGE HAS BEEN
DEMONSTRATED -- UP BY THE THE
THE THE JANITORS MANY OF WHOM
ARE HERE TODAY BUT IN GENERAL
THROUGHOUT THIS NATION.
AND RAISING ATTENTION BEFORE IT
WAS COOL BEFORE IT WAS HOLLYWOOD
BEFORE IT WAS POPULAR -- BUT I I
THINK DESERVES A GREAT DEAL OF
CREDIT.
AND SO I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
THAT CAME OUT AND EVERYONE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS THREE
FOUR FIVE YEARS -- PLUS THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISING ATTENTION --
THAT HAVE BEEN FIRED THAT HAVE
BEEN HARASSED FOR RAISING
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE FOR YOUR
COURAGEOUS NESS -- AND I I'D
EXTEND GREAT GRATITUDE AND
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THIS BILL AND
IT DOES -- IT DOES HAVE AN AYE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR
AND I'M HOPEFUL.
THAT WE CAN GET THIS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S THAT ARE NEW
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND AND FINALLY
MOVE ON THIS I THINK IT MAKES
SENSE TO HAVE THOSE DOING THE
TRAINING THAT UNDERSTAND.
HOW TO TRAIN THOSE THAT ARE PUT
IN SITUATIONS THAT CAN BE VERY
DANGEROUS I THINK IT MAY IT WILL
MAKE FOR A SAFER AND HAPPIER
WORKPLACE WHICH I THINK WILL
MAKE FOR A?
BETTER EMPLOYEES FOR THE
EMPLOYERS TO SO I THINK IT IT
REALLY IS A WIN WIN SITUATION
AND WITH THAT.
SOME OF HIS OFFICE WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE I WOULD AND JUST IN IN
TERMS OF THE OPPOSITION IT SEEMS
FROM THE COMMENTS YOU DON'T
TRULY UNDERSTAND THE IMPETUS
BEHIND THIS BILL.
AND THAT THE TRAINERS THEMSELVES
HAVE TO ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND THE
WORKPLACE THE CULTURE -- THE THE
EVEN COUNTRY OF ORIGIN OF THE
FOLKS WHO -- THEY'RE TALKING TO
IT IS VERY EASY FROM A LEGAL
STANDPOINT I GUESS FROM A
QUALIFIED TRAINER TO COME IN AND
SAY DON'T LET SOMEBODY TO THIS
TO YOU.
THAT'S AN EASY THING WE'VE ALL
BEEN THROUGH SEXUAL HARASSMENT
TRAINING AND WE'VE SCOFFED AT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT ARE TOLD
TO US.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
LARGELY A FEMALE POPULATION WHO
IS WORKING BY THEMSELVES AT
NIGHT OFTEN AFRAID OF BEING
EXPOSED FOR THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS BEING -- HAVING THEIR
SPOUSES BE TOLD SOMEHOW THEY'RE
COMPLICIT IN THIS -- CONCERN
ABOUT THEIR COMMUNITY -- THEIR
WORKPLACE THE THE I I WOULD
VENTURE TO SAY ANYONE WHO HAS
WATCHED RAPE ON THE NIGHT SHIFT
UNDERSTANDS WHY THE MOST
APPROPRIATE TRAINER TO TRAIN
ABOUT THE SUBJECT WOULD BE
ANOTHER JANITOR SOMEBODY WHO
UNDERSTANDS AS CONDITIONS.
THEIR THEIR POSITION IN LIFE IN
WHAT IS HAPPENING TO THEM AND
ALSO UNDERSTAND THE FACT THAT WE
COMING HERE WHO DON'T HAVE THE
SAME PROTECTIONS OF LOT FROM
THEIR COUNTRY OF ORIGIN.
AND DON'T KNOW THE SPECIFICS OF
WHAT -- IS APPROPRIATE IS NOT
APPROPRIATE IN FROM THE ROLE OF
THE JANITOR TO BE ABLE TO ASK
THOSE QUESTIONS IN A COMFORTABLE
SETTING NOT TO SOME STRANGER
THAT YOU DON'T KNOW BUT SOMEBODY
WHO HAS -- WHO UNDERSTANDS YOU
AND AND UNDERSTAND YOUR LANGUAGE
IS IMPERATIVE AND SO I DON'T
KNOW QUITE FRANKLY -- I I I HOPE.
THAT THAT PERHAPS PEOPLE HAVEN'T
SEEN RIP ON THE NIGHT SHIFT
COULD SEE WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE AND HAVE TO I'M NOT
TALKING ABOUT BAD JOKES SIR.
OR INAPPROPRIATE COMMENTS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RAPE AND ASSAULT
AND HOW WOMEN CAN PROTECT
THEMSELVES FROM THAT I ALSO WHEN
AND WITH ONE LOOK NO TO REALLY
THINK -- OUR OUR MAIL JANITORS
WHO CAN I HAVE SEEN SO MANY MALE
JANITORS COME OUT IN THAT THAT
SHOWS JUST HOW FAR WE'VE COME IN
THIS MOVEMENT AND HOW FAR.
ON THE EMPOWERMENT OF THESE
WORKERS HAVE MATTERED BOTH -- TO
THEMSELVES AND TO OTHERS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY ABOUT
THINK TYLER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU SO
MEMBERS CAN -- PREVENTS ACTOR
CALL WILL PLEASE.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA.
CARILLO.
DEEP.
HI DEEP I CAN SALAS AYE GONZALEZ
I JONES SAWYER THREE OF US.
OKAY SO PLACE THAT BILL ON CALL.
END OF THE SUMMER BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A A SIGN OR AND THIS IS
YOUR COMMITTEE MEMBER WOULD YOU.
MIND RETURNING TO THE DAIS AND
ALLOWING SOME OF OUR NON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESENT
[inaudible]
SEC.
A NEXUS I IN ORDER IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA.
THE TICKET TAKE A LOOK WHO ARE
AVAILABLE BILL WE SEE WHAT IT IS --
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT LINES
WHAT I AM -- TWENTY ONE I WILL
SECOND IT OKAY SO THE MOTION OF
A SOME OF IT IS ALSO SECOND FROM
AS A MEMBER IDEA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND AND
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT THIS BILL
CONFORMS THE CALIFORNIA FAMILY
RIGHTS ACTOR CA.
F. OUR A TO THE UNIQUE WORK
SCHEDULE AND CIRCUMSTANCES A
FLIGHT CREW MEMBERS.
AS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
ALREADY DONE.
THE CFRA ALLOWS FOR EMPLOYEES TO
TAKE TWELVE WEEKS OF PAID OR
UNPAID JOB PROTECTED LEAVE AND
KEEP THEIR SAME HEALTH COVERAGE
IF THEY HAVE WORK.
TWELVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY HOURS
IN THE PREVIOUS TWELVE MONTHS
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
NATURE OF THEIR WORK FULL TIME
FLIGHT CREW MEMBERS WORK A
SCHEDULE OF THREE TO FOUR DAYS
AND THIS DOES NOT MAKE THEM
ELIGIBLE FOR THE CFRA.
THIS MEANS THAT DURING
VULNERABLE TIMES FLIGHT CREWS DO
NOT HAVE ALL OF THE PROTECTIONS
OF THE C. F. R. A. MOST NOTABLY
THEY MAY.
NOT BE ABLE TO KEEP THEIR
EMPLOYER PROVIDED HEALTH
INSURANCE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
EIGHT WOULD MORE APPROPRIATELY
USE THAT FEDERAL FAMILY AND
MEDICAL LEAVE ACT WORK OUR
REQUIREMENT OF FIVE HUNDRED AND
FOUR HOURS FOR FLIGHT CREW.
CFRA ELIGIBILITY SO THAT DURING
FAMILY MEDICAL LEAVE -- FLIGHT
CREW MEMBERS WITH WHAT UP ONE
HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT BEING
UNINSURED AND THEY CAN FOCUS ON
THEIR FAMILIES I BELIEVE IS THE
COMMON SENSE MEASURE.
THAT EXTENDS VALUABLE BENEFITS
OF THE CFR A TO OUR FLIGHT CREWS.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU AND WE
HAVE A NO WITNESSES TODAY WE HAD
A WITNESS THAT WAS.
TRYING TO MAKE IT UP BUT GOT
WAYLAID SO -- SAVE ON A SET UP
WITH THAT KIND OF DAY.
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
AND JUST GO AHEAD HIS NAME JUST
NAME AN ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION.
A TURN ON GOOD AFTERNOON LIST
SORENSON WITH COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA REPRESENTING
ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS --
I DO WHAT I'M HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF ACTUALLY OF OUR
ASSOCIATION OF FLIGHT ATTENDANTS
AND WE'RE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF THE SPELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP ROUTE
WITH THE TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
IF NOT ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SUPPOSE COMING ABOUT THE COMING
FOR SOMETHING ELSE SAY ONE
OPPOSITION OKAY -- WILL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE.
THE QUESTIONS -- MISS BONTA WE
HAVE A MOTION.
ON THE FLOOR DO PASSED TO
APPROACH WAS LIKE MAKE ANY
CLOSING COMMENTS RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU MADAM SECTOR CALL
WILL PLEASE.
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA FIVE KALRA
AYE FLORA CARILLO.
DEEP I EAT AYE GONZALEZ JONES
SAWYER THREE OF US ALRIGHT MR
BONTA PUT THAT ON THE ON CALL
AND THEN WAIT FOR THE MEMBERS
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
WHAT'S IN YOUR SANTIAGO.
LET IN LINE ITEM FOR SB.
FIVE SIXTY I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR PRECIADO OPPORTUNITY
PRESENT ON AB FIVE SIXTY WHICH
WOULD ENSURE THAT -- TAP A RAPE
HERE DOLLARS ARE NOT USING
UTILITIES TO EITHER FAVOR --
UNION ACTIVITIES OR DISCOURAGE
THEM PLAIN AND SIMPLE -- AND WE
HAVE THE WITNESS WITH US AS WELL.
OKAY TO CHAIR -- I GUESS THAT'S
ALL MEMBERS I'M SORRY -- MIKE
MONACAN BEHALF THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES
WERE THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
AS SEVEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO
STATED IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL WE HAVE
SPURRED AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
A MOVE THE BILL MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAP BROAD WITH THAT
UTILITY WORKERS UNION AMERICAN
ENGINEERS AND SCIENTISTS OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION I'LL SECOND
THAT MOTION -- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT BRING BACK ANY FURTHER
COMMENT.
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
PRICE WE HAVE A MOTION TO PASS A
POSTER SANTIAGO ANY CLOSING
COMMENTS RESPECT AND THAT'S WHAT
I WILL MISS CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
THANK YOU -- MADAM SECRETARY.
WILL PLEASE OCEAN CITY PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA CREEL.
DEEP HI DEEP AYE GONZALEZ.
JONES SAWYER THREE OF US BILLS
ARE RIGHT WE WILL PLACE THAT ON
CALL.
MR O'DONNELL ITEM NINETEEN AB.
SIXTEEN THIRTEEN ARE YOU READY
MISTER CHAIR.
ALL I'M READY OKAY AND YOU LOOK
AT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN DEFINES
PUBLIC WORKS TO INCLUDE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITY PROJECTS THAT
RECEIVE FUNDING THROUGH CONDUIT
REVENUE BONDS.
THIS WOULD ENSURE THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK ON THESE
PROJECTS RECEIVE PREVAILING
WAGES AND ALLOW THEM TO BENEFIT
FROM APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
CONDUIT REVENUE BOND FINE IS
FINANCING COODINATED BY A NON
PROFIT OR PUBLIC ENTITY.
SUCH AS THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
FINANCING AUTHORITY UNDER THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE.
THE STATE LOSES REVENUE ON THESE
BONDS AS INVESTORS DO NOT PAY
TAXES ON THEM.
INTERN THE BORROWER BENEFITS BY
RECEIVING LOWER INTEREST RATES.
UNDER EXISTING LAW CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES THAT ARE
FUNDED BY THE STATE EDUCATION
BONDS ARE REQUIRED. TO COMPLY
WITH PREVAILING WAGE AND HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS UNDER THE
FIELD ACT.
PROJECTS THAT AREN'T FUND THAT
ARE FUNDED WITH CONDIT BOND
REVENUE BONDS DO NOT.
WE MUST ENSURE THAT THOSE
WORKING ON THESE STATE
SUBSIDIZED PROJECTS ARE SKILLED
AND QUALIFIED THIS IS A POLICY
THAT KEEPS GIVING.
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS MIDDLE
CLASS JOBS WHICH HAVE A POSITIVE
IMPACT.
ON OUR PEOPLE AND OUR ECONOMY.
THIS BILL IS MODELED AFTER A
BILL THE COMMITTEE PASSED A FEW
YEARS AGO DEFINING PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS TO INCLUDE GENERAL
ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS.
FUNDED.
BY CONDUIT REVENUE BONDS WITH ME
HERE TODAY A CAESAR DAY IS FROM
THIS CALIFORNIA STATE BUILDING
TRADES AND CONSTRUCTION COUNCIL.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE THIS FEATURE MEMBER SAYS
RDS ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL -- THE PROVINCES OF THIS
BILL WHEN THE THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAHLE FOR
CARRYING IT -- WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS A NEW FINANCING
MECHANISM THAT HAS BEEN SORT OF
COLLABORATING OR EXPANDING --
OVER TIME AND OVER TIME WE'VE
DONE IS ALLOW THE LABOR CODE TO
KIND OF CATCH UP WITH A LOT OF
THESE NEW FINANCING MECHANISMS
THAT ARE PROVIDED TO PRIVATE
ENTITIES FOR ESSENTIALLY PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS.
WHEN YOU BUILD USING THE
PREVAILING WAGE YOU'RE ACTUALLY
CREATING MIDDLE CLASS JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AS WAS STATED BUT
ALSO EMBEDDED IN THE PREVAILING
WAGE IS PENSION AND HEALTH CARE
AND A PARTNERSHIP CONTRIBUTIONS
TO GIVE BACK TO THE PRESSURE
PROGRAM SO THEY COULD TRAIN THE
NEXT GENERATION OF SKILLED
WORKERS?
WE'VE ALSO CREATED A PIPELINE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH MANY COMMUNITY
GROUPS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ENSURE THERE'S PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS FOR A
PRESSURE PROGRAM PREPARATIONS.
THERE'S A LOT OF INTEREST IN
THAT BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING AT
TARGETED POPULATIONS I FOR
EXAMPLE UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED EMANCIPATED YOUTH
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM WOMEN
WHICH ARE TRYING TO GET MORE
WOMEN TO THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES.
WHEN A PUBLIC WORKS PROJECT
CARRIES A PREVAILING WAGE IT
CARRIES A LOT OF THOSE
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S ACCESS FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS TO WORK ON THOSE
PUBLIC WORKS?
NOTHINGIS MORE IMPORTANT TO
BUILD AN EDUCATIONAL FACILITY
USING HIGH QUALITY SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKERS FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WEBSITE BUT THAT.
THIS TO TURN MEMBERS CAITLIN
VEGA FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALL SECURE AND STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE OF THE GREATEST
CHALLENGES WE FACE IN CALIFORNIA
IS THE DISAPPEARING MIDDLE CLASS
AND THE FACT THAT TOO MANY JOBS
I LEAVE WORKERS STUCK IN POVERTY
WHAT THIS BILL REALLY IS ABOUT
IS THAT WHEN EVER WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY -- ESPECIALLY IN
REGARDS TO A PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECT TO CREATE OPPORTUNITIES
TO A GOOD CAREER TO GOOD JOBS TO
STABILITY FOR FAMILIES WE SHOULD
BE TAKING THOSE OPPORTUNITIES SO
WHAT HERE INSTRUCTS THE PART OF
THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ALSO SUPPORT.
NAME AFFILIATION POSITION.
MIKE WESTWOOD DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
MATT BROUGHT FOR THE TEAMSTERS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MATT CRIMMINS ON WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THEY WERE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY OF ANY OTHER ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO PASS TO A
PROBES FROM OUR APPROACH SHARE
SOME RUBIO SALAS SECONDED BY
SOME RADIO.
OF ANY CLOSING COMMENTS MISTER
DONALD AS FOR NEVER.
YEAH.
I THANK YOU.
MATT IS ACTUALLY CALLED --
PLEASE.
MOTIONS YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA.
KALRA AYE FLORA PRIO DEEP HI THE
BY AND SALAS GONZALEZ I JONES
SAWYER.
THREE OF US STILL SOME.
ALL RIGHTS WILL PLACE THAT ON
CALL [inaudible]
SOMEONE GONZALEZ.
ITEM THREE A LINE ITEM THREE A.
B..
FIVE FIVE FIVE I NAY PROCEED
MANY EVERY YEAR RIGHT HERE ALL
RIGHT.
THANK YOU -- MISTER CHAIR AND
GOOD AFTERNOON.
AB FIVE FIVE FIVE ALLOWS
EMPLOYEES TO USE AT LEAST FIVE
PAID SICK DAYS A YEAR WITHOUT
FACING WEIGHT LOSS OR
RETALIATION. FIVE YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIA SET A NATIONAL
STANDARD BY PROVIDING SIX POINT
FIVE MILLION WORKERS WITH LONG
OVERDUE PROTECTIONS OF THREE
PAID SICK DAYS A YEAR.
OTHER US STATES IN MAJOR CITIES
FOLLOWED ALONG AND SOME AREAS IN
IN METRO CALIFORNIAN FACT -- HAD
HAD PRECEDED US BUT THESE AREAS
ALL HAVE A HIGHER STANDARD
CALIFORNIA -- CITY SUCH AS SAN
FRANCISCO OAKLAND AND REBUILD
BERKELEY LOS ANGELES AND SAN
DIEGO A PASSER OWN ORDINANCES
GRANNY WORKERS WITH EVEN GREATER
PAID SICK LEAVE BENEFITS THE
NATIONAL STANDARD.
RANGES BETWEEN FIVE AND SEVEN
DAYS BUT WORKERS WHO CAN'T
BENEFIT FROM LOCAL ORDINANCES
STILL DON'T HAVE SUFFICIENT PAID
SICK LEAVE AND ARE MORE LIKELY
TO REPORT GOING TO WORK WITH A
CONTAGIOUS ILLNESS AND RISK
INFECTING OTHERS.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS HAPPENS OFTEN
BECAUSE FOR WORKING FAMILIES
STRUGGLING TO MAKE ENDS MEET.
EVEN IF YOU I'M PAID DAYS OFF
COULD COST THEM THEIR ENTIRE
MONTHLY BUDGET FOR GROCERIES.
FLU RELATED HOSPITALIZATION AND
MORTALITY RATES THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS HAVE BEEN UNPRECEDENTED
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION REPORTS OF PEOPLE
WHO FELL ILL WITH THE FLU.
NEEDED AT LEAST ONE WEEK TO
RECOVER.
IT'S HIGH TIME THAT WE STRENGTH
IN THIS CRITICAL SAFETY NET
STOPPING WORKING FAMILIES IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY MUST CHOOSE
BETWEEN SACRIFICING THEIR PAY IN
COMING TO WORK SICK.
IN ANTICIPATION OF A THE
OPPOSITION'S ARGUMENTS I WILL
REMIND FOLKS OF FIVE YEARS AGO
THEY WARNED US THAT THIS WOULD
BE A JOB KILLER THE JOBS WOULD
OF COURSE FLEE FROM CALIFORNIA
AS A RESULT.
OF PROVIDING JUST THREE PAID
SICK DAYS AND I'M SURE WE WILL
HEAR THAT AGAIN TODAY PERHAPS
NOT WITH A JOB KILLER TITLE BUT
THE SAME THING.
I WOULD VENTURE TO ASK THEM HOW
MANY JOBS AND IMPACT -- HAVE
HAVE BEEN LOST IN CALIFORNIA AS
A RESULT OF PROVIDING PAID SICK
DAYS IN FACT WE KNOW THAT --
THERE THERE HASN'T BEEN AT TO
OUR KNOWLEDGE RECORDED LOSS OF A
JOB AS A RESULT OF LIEU OF
PROVIDING PAID SICK DAYS AND IN
FACT OTHER PEOPLE HAVE FOLLOWED
ALONG IN PROVIDED EVEN MORE.
WE ARE ONE OF THE ONLY.
FIRST WORLD COUNTRIES IF YOU
WELL WHO DON'T RECOGNIZE
INDIVIDUALS NEED TO TAKE TIME
OFF WHEN THEY'RE SICK -- AND AS
WE MOVE FORWARD THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THAT WOULD BE A
STANDARD -- FOR THE ENTIRE STATE
THAT MAKES SENSE I WANT TO
REMIND PEOPLE THAT IF YOU LIVE
IN WORK IN A CITY LIKE SAN DIEGO
YOU COULD LITERALLY -- WORK AT
THE SAME ESTABLISHMENT PART TIME
ACROSS CITY LINES HAVE A
DIFFERENTIATION OF ANYWHERE
BETWEEN -- TWO AND SEVEN DAYS OF
OF SICK TIME SO THIS IT DOESN'T
MAKE A LOT OF SENSE -- YOU COULD
BE WORKING FOR THE SAME COMPANY
AND HAVE COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
BENEFITS AND IT'S TIME TO
STANDARDIZE THOSE AND PUSH THEM
UP JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR NINE THANK YOU.
WITNESSES SUPPORT YES HELLO MY
NAME IS JENNY CASSIDY I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA WORK
AND FAMILY COALITION WERE
STATEWIDE ALLIANCE.
OF ORGANIZATIONS AND INDIVIDUALS
AND WE'RE UNITED BEHIND --
WORKPLACE POLICIES THAT HELP
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES THRIVE AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
FIVE FIVE FIVE AND WE HAVE FOUND
THE PAID SICK DAYS IS REALLY A
VERY NO NONSENSE POLICY THAT
REALLY DOES WONDERS TO HELP THE
HEALTH AND WELL BEING IN THE
ECONOMIC SECURITY OF OUR
FAMILIES IN THE STATE.
BUT FURTHERMORE IT'S ALSO THE
NUMBER ONE THING THE CDC SAYS TO
DO WHEN YOU HAVE A CONTAGIOUS --
SICKNESS THAT YOU NEED TO STAY
HOME AND SO IT'S ALSO FOR US
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE FAMILIES
IT'S ALSO REALLY ABOUT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
EVEN OUR BUSINESSES AND AND HOW
WE THRIVE IN CALIFORNIA -- I
THINK THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER GNZALEZ
MENTIONED IS THAT YOU KNOW
ALTHOUGH THE US IS QUITE ALONE
IN BEING ONE OF THE FEW
COUNTRIES THAT DOES NOT PROVIDE
THIS AS A FEDERAL POLICY WE IN
CALIFORNIA REALLY AREN'T ALONE
IN THAT MORE AND MORE STATES.
AND LOCALITIES ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY SOMETHING LIKE FORTY
THREE PAID SICK DAYS LAWS OF
VARIOUS SIZES BUT MOST ARE FIVE
AND MORE
AND SO IT REALLY IS TIME TO BE
ABLE TO EXPAND THIS -- Là A
LITTLE BIT FURTHER AND ALSO JUST
TO KIND OF HI LATE A LITTLE BIT
OF WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ
SAID.
IT'S REALLY -- IN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE JUST SEEING SO MANY
FAMILIES STRUGGLING THAT EVEN
JUST LOSING ONE TO TWO DAYS TO
PAY WE'RE SEEING IN OUR
COALITION MORE AND MORE PEOPLE.
HAVING SOMETHING LIKE SOME YOU
KNOW ECONOMIC THINGS THAT SEEM
KIND OF SMALL REALLY IMPACTING
THE ABILITY TO PAY RENT THE
ABILITY TO BUY GROCERIES.
SO THIS REALLY DOES HAVE TO BE
EXTENDED RIGHT NOW PEOPLE CAN
TAKE THREE BUT LIKE MY KIDS GOT
REALLY SICK WITH THE FLU LAST
YEAR AND THEY DID NEED A WEEK TO
RECOVER.
SO YOU KNOW ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE FINDING IS THAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO KIDS IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE THEIR
PARENTS NEARBY?
I'M NOT JUST FOR WHAT YOU'RE
DOING FOR YOUR KIDS GIVING THE
MEDICINE ETCETERA BUT STUDIES
SHOW THAT THAT PSYCHOLOGICAL
COMFORT AND CARE OF HAVING
SOMEBODY CARE FOR YOU WHEN
YOU'RE SICK ESPECIALLY A CHILD
AND HAVING THEIR PARENT THERE.
IS REALLY KEY TO THEM GETTING
BETTER SO I FEEL LIKE THIS IS
JUST A VERY HUMANE GOOD THING
THAT WE NEED TO DO IN CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M VERY -- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR HEARING MY TESTIMONY
AND I'M -- JUST I ALSO REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
OF THE COMMITTEE JESSICA BARTOLO
WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY WE'RE THRILLED FOR
THIS AND THIS LEGISLATION AND
URGE ARRIVAL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MITCH DYER CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
BREAK A HR WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PLAN MILLERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HEY THANK YOU CHAIR MY NAME'S
TONY GOMEZ WITH A CALIFORNIA
WORKING FAMILY COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MATT BROUGHT FOR THE TEAMSTERS
AND CONSUMER ATTORNEYS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
YOUR TRADE WITH WORK SAFE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MY ANGER MAYES FAILURE
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
REBECCA GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO IS HERE YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TAYLOR JACKSON THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
PLEASE A CHAIR WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DANIELLE URBAN WITH LEGALLY THAT
WORK IN SAN FRANCISCO AND CENTER
FOR WORKERS RIGHTS IN SACRAMENTO
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MEANWHILE HER WELL A. R. P.
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SISTER DE ESTE BILLION
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
EMILY MATHIS UT W. ASKED ME
LOCAL THIRTY NINE THIRTY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MEGAN SERVERS CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CATHERINE PORTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HELPING ELSE LONG
COLLABORATIVE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MARC CURTIS
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY WE
ARE HERE IN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION.
ON AB FIVE FIVE FIVE WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR TAKING
INTO CONSIDERATION THE LOCAL
ORDINANCE ISSUE AND PRE EMPTING
MOST PROVISIONS OF THE LAW.
PART OF THE AMENDMENTS WERE
REQUESTING IS THAT IT BE ACROSS
THE BOARD PREEMPTION -- I DO
UNDERSTAND THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
OF ALLOWING ADDITIONAL DAYS OF
SICK LEAVE HOWEVER FOR EMPLOYERS --
OVER THERE ALREADY TRYING TO
STRUGGLE WITH ALL THE DIFFERENT
LOCAL ORDINANCES DIFFERENT WAGE
RATES FOR DIFFERENT ORDINANCES
AND ACROSS THE BOARD PREEMPTION
IS SOMETHING THAT WE THINK WOULD
ESPECIALLY HELP -- EMPLOYERS IN
THE SITUATION ADDITIONALLY WE
ARE ASKING THAT -- THE RATE OF
PAY BE BASED ON THE BASE RATE
AND THE REASON FOR THAT IS IS
THAT THERE'S A LOT OF ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE WITH REGARD TO A
EMPLOYEES TAKE ADVANTAGE OF PAID
SICK LEAVE.
ON HOLIDAYS SO WHEN THEY'RE
GETTING THEIR HIGHER RATE OF PAY
AND ADDITIONALLY AT THE WHEN
THEY'RE AT THE END OF HARVEST
AND THINGS LIKE THAT WHEN THEY
ARE AT A HIGHER RATE OF PAY
BECAUSE THEY ALL CALL IN SICK AT
THE SAME TIME.
BECAUSE THEY'LL MAKE MORE MONEY
ON THOSE DAYS THAN IF THEY
CALLED IN SICK HONORED ON A
REGULAR WORK DAY ADDITIONALLY
AND THERE'S DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION IN THE BILL FOR
I. H. S. S. WORKERS.
ARE OF THE INDUSTRY AND WE FEEL
THAT IF THERE'S DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION FOR ONE INDUSTRY
AGAIN IT SHOULD BE APPLICABLE
ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND LASTLY -- VERIFICATION AGAIN
THIS IS TO HELP ALLEVIATE SOME
OF THE ABUSE OF THE SICK LEAVE
LAW AND AND IN SAN DIEGO YOU'RE
ALLOWED VERIFICATION AFTER THREE
CONSECUTIVE DAYS OF SICKLY. FOR
THE LAST TWO FOR THE FOURTH AND
FIFTH DAY AND THE EMPLOYER IS A
LOT TO ASK FOR A DOCTOR'S NOTE
IF YOU TAKE FIVE CONSECUTIVE
FORTY FIVES TWO CONSECUTIVE DAYS
WERE ASKING FOR THAT AS WELL.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE ARE IN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
CHRISTOPHER KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDS
ASSOCIATION MY COLLEAGUES AT THE
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION.
IN TWENTY FOURTEEN I ACTUALLY
HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
WITH THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN HONOR A
BE FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO AND
SHORTLY AFTER IT WAS SIGNED SHE
ACTUALLY CAME.
IN SAN DIEGO AND SPOKE AT OUR
ANNUAL CONVENTION -- ABOUT THAT
NEW BILL SO WE HAD A LOT OF
HISTORY ON THIS MEASURE I JUST
WANTED TO ADD TO TO CONCERNS IN
ADDITION TO THOSE ENUMERATED BY
MISS CURTIS WHICH IS.
THERE IS COST US PARTICULARLY
FOR THE SMALL BUSINESS SMALL
EMPLOYER IN THE STATE.
AND YOU HAVE TO TAKE IT IN A
BROADER CONTEXT.
IN THAT WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
BASED SALES TAX RATE THE HIGHEST
PERSONAL INCOME TAX RATES.
THE HIGHEST ENERGY IN WORKERS
COMP COSTS ANA AMONGST THE
WESTERN STATES IT CETERA.
THE OTHER THING IS WE ARE A VERY
FAMILY FRIENDLY -- IT LEAVE THE
STATE -- THE NATIONAL CONFERENCE
OF STATE LEGISLATURES HAS OFTEN
RAIN CALIFORNIA M<c.cyan> AMONGST</c>
THE MOST FAMILY FRIENDLY FOR ALL
THOSE PROTECTED LEAVES SO.
IN PARTICULARLY THE AMENDMENTS
THAT -- MISS CURTIS AS OUTLINED
IS WHAT OUR ORGANIZATIONS DESIRE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
THE CALL RISE CALIFORNIA MANY
FACTORS IN TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION I JUST WANT TO KNOW
ONE CORRECTION FROM THE ANALYSIS
WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED NOT
OPPOSED TO THE BILL -- AND WE
ARE HAVE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
BECAUSE WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE. TO DEAL WITH --
SOME CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
SEEING IN OUR INDUSTRY RELATED
TO THE MISUSE OF THE PAID SICK
LEAVE BENEFIT WE WANT TO
PRESERVE IT FOR THAT -- INTENDED
PURPOSE OF THAT BENEFIT AND IF I
CAN JUST OFFER AN EXAMPLE AND
RELATED TO THE MINIMUM
INCREMENTS THAT THE PAID SICK
LEAVE CAN BE USED WE HAVE
COMPANIES IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AS YOU KNOW TRAFFIC IS HORRIBLE
THERE. FOR MANUFACTURERS WHO HAS
AN ATTENDANCE POLICY THEY'RE
SEEING THEIR STAFF INVOKE THE
PAID SICK LEAVE BECAUSE THEY
KNOW THAT THEY'RE COMING AND
GOING TO BE COMING IN TO WORK
LATE AND THEY DON'T WANT THEIR
ATTENDANCE.
RECORD HIT SO IS THOSE TYPES OF
INSTANCES THAT WE'D LIKE -- TO
SEE FIX WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE
AND WE ARE.
BUT AT THIS POINT WE ARE
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU OKAY I WILL
TREAT YOU AS THE THIRD EXPERT
WITNESSES IS FALLS UNDER THE SIX
MINUTES.
OR ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
GETTING AND SOME OF THE
CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION REPOSE THANK YOU.
MORE IS REGISTERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
AND WE ARE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT -- NO ONE ELSE
OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
IS THERE A MOTION ON THIS.
I'LL SECOND THAT.
YES I HAVE A QUESTION.
PLEASE.
MA'AM I IN IN READING THIS BILL --
I COMPLETELY SUPPORT THE THE THE
THE IDEA OF GIVING A SICK LEAVE
TO WORKERS -- AND AND I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT -- S AS AN
EMPLOYEE IF IF YOU AND I HAVE A
COMMON COLD OR EVEN IF WE HAVE.
A MINOR FLU WE CAN JUST TAKE OFF
THREE OR FOUR DAYS AND GO TO CVS
AND BY SOME PLUMAS IN IN IN IN
BE OKAY WITH IT BUT YOU ARE YOU
NOT OPEN TO REQUIRING THAT -- ON
THE LEASE ON THE FIFTH DAY THAT.
IF IF WE DO GO THROUGH IT WE
REALLY THAT SICK -- SHOULD WE AT
LEAST.
GET A DOCTOR'S NOTE.
SO -- YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
DISPUTE ABOUT THAT FIRST OF ALL
WHAT WE HAVE FOUND IS MOST
PEOPLE DON'T USE FIVE
CONSECUTIVE DAYS I MEAN THERE
MIGHT BE A THEY THEY TEND TO USE
A DAY -- AND SO IF IT WAS ON THE
FIFTH DAY I GUESS IF YOU'RE SICK
FOR A DAY THEN IT'S THE FIFTH
DAY.
SECOND WITH THAT IS THE REALITY
THAT -- A LOT OF WORKERS DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO A DOCTOR.
AND THAT IS UNFORTUNATELY THE
TRUTH AND WE STILL SUFFER FROM
THAT IN THIS STATE AND SO -- OR
THE COST OF OF GOING TO THE
DOCTORS SO HIGH ESPECIALLY FOR
LOW WAGE WORKERS -- WHO DON'T
HAVE THAT ACCESS?
WE STILL HAVE IN THIS IN THIS
STATE UNINSURABLE FOLKS AND SO
WE'RE ASKING PEOPLE TO ADD AN
ADDITIONAL COST ON TO SOMETHING
THAT LET'S BE HONEST IT'S EARNED
SICK TIME IT'S NOT GIVEN TO AN
EMPLOYEE IT'S EARNED THROUGHOUT
THEIR YEAR OF SERVICE -- AND SO
YOU KNOW IT IN AND RECOGNIZING
ALL OF THAT -- WE DON'T FEEL
THAT IT IS APPROPRIATE -- TO TO
BE ASKING WORKERS WHO CAN BE ALL
DIFFERENT SITUATIONS FOR YOUR
EYE ON THE FIFTH DAY IT'S
PROBABLY EVER BEFORE OUT FIVE
DAYS WOULD PROBABLY.
SPEND THE FIFTY DOLLAR COPAY TO
GO TO THE DOCTOR AND AND WE
COULD GET AN OUT -- BUT WE'RE IN
A MUCH BETTER SITUATION AND AND
AND THE TRUTH IS WE WOULD NEVER
BE EXPECTED.
TO THERE'S ALSO SOME PRIVACY
CONCERNS WITH THAT -- IN IN THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T NECESSARILY --
WANT TO FORCE WORKERS TO TELL
THEIR EMPLOYER WHAT EXACT
SICKNESS THEY HAVE OR WHAT
DOCTOR THEIR SCENE.
I'M AND FINALLY I'D SAY THE
IMPETUS FOR ME WRITING THIS BILL
IN THE FIRST PLACE IT'S KIND OF
INTERESTING BECAUSE WE TALK A
LOT ABOUT SICK DAYS NOW IN THE
FLU -- REALLY IN THAT OUR OUR
WORKERS THAT WE HAD HERE BEFORE
WERE THE REASON I I A BROKE THE
SPELL WHEN I WAS A UNION LEADER
AND ORGANIZER -- TALKING TO TWO
NEW WORKERS WHO HAD BEEN
UNIONIZE WOULD ASK THEM LIKE HOW
YOU KNOW WHAT'S THE GREATEST
THING ABOUT HAVING A UNION AND
YOU THINK IT BE LIKE THEY'RE
GETTING A PAY INCREASE OR
THEY'RETHEY'RE GETTING --
HEALTH CARE WAGES AND TIME AND
TIME AGAIN WE HEAR STORIES
ESPECIALLY FROM SINGLE MOMS LIKE.
IF MY SON'S SCHOOL CALLS IN HE
SAID I CAN GO PICK HIM UP AND
I'M NOT GONNA LOSE MY JOB.
YOU KNOW I A IF I'M STATE I CAN
STAY HOME WITH MY KIDS WHEN
THEY'RE SICK.
SO THE IMPETUS ME WRITING THIS
BILL IN THE FIRST PLACE HAD TO
DO.
MUCH MORE SO -- YOU KNOW I I'D
NEVER TAKEN A SICK DAY IN MY
LIFE.
BUT I HAD TAKEN OFF WORK TO GO
GET MY KIDS BECAUSE I WAS.
AND JULIE SENDING THEM TO SCHOOL
WITH A FEVER -- AND YOU GET
CAUGHT I MEAN THAT'S WHAT CAN'T
WORKING PARENTS TEND TO DO -- OR
THEY THROW UP AT SCHOOL YOU HAVE
TO GET THEM RIGHT AND SO IT'S
NOT A SITUATION BY WHICH YOU
COULD HAVE MULTIPLE KIDS AND AND
THEY COULD HAVE A COMMON COLD.
AND SO ONE KID SEC ONE DAY TWO
DAYS THREE DAYS AND THEN THE
NEXT KID GET SECOND YOUR HOME
FIVE DAYS AND YOU'VE NEVER GONE
TO THE DOCTOR AND IT'S NOT
UNREASONABLE.
AND SO I JUST THINK THAT THOSE
ALL THOS EXTENUATING
CIRCUMSTANCES I FIND IT
UNFORTUNATE -- THAT WE DON'T
TRUST OUR OWN WORK FORCE TO TELL
US THE TRUTH.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S ONE OF
THE MOST DISTURBING THINGS ABOUT
THESE CONVERSATIONS WERE HAVING
IS THAT WE DON'T PUT THAT TRUST
IN OUR WORKERS THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO MAKE.
OUR OUR WHATEVER WORK WE DO IF
IT AS BOSSES IF YOU WILL -- WERE
SUPERVISORS THEY'RE THE ONES WHO
ARE ACTUALLY PERFORMING THE WORK
TO MAKE A SUCCESSFUL AND
PROFITABLE AND YET WE DON'T.
TRUST IF THEY SAY THEY'RE SICK
OR THEIR LOVED ONE TO STICK OR
THEY NEED TO STAY HOME --
THERE'S ALSO A A AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR FOR ON MENTAL HEALTH REASONS
TO STAY HOME THAT'S ALSO YOU CAN
BE SICK ON STRESS.
AND SO THERE'S SO MANY DIFFERENT
ASPECTS TO IT TO WHITE PEOPLE
NEED SOMETIMES A DAY OFF OR TWO
DAYS OFF AND WE THINK UP TO FIVE
DAYS OFF IS REASONABLE -- THAT
WE JUST DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO
HAVE THEM EXPLAIN THAT WE ARE
PRESENT AB PANTENE THE SAN DIEGO
ORDINANCE THAT REQUIRES A FOURTH
AND FIFTH DAY TO HAVE.
A NO WE TRIED VERY HARD TO WORK
WITH OUR WITH COMPANIES -- THAT
THAT OPERATE MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS TO HAVE ONE SET OF
RULES I WAS NOTICING MY DAUGHTER
WAS WAITRESSING AND SAN DIEGO
AND HER HER AT SIXTY OF CRUEL ON
HER PAYCHECK.
IS I MEAN IT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE
WORKER IT'S CONFUSING BECAUSE
THEY HAVE STATE AND CITY LAWS
THAT THAT READ DIFFERENTLY --
AND SO WE DID WORK THROUGH A LOT
OF PRE EMPTION ISSUES AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY GONNA PREAMP THAT AS
WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANKS.
FOR CONTINUING -- THIS -- FIGHT
AS WELL FOR THE FOR THE WORKERS
AND AGAIN I THINK HAVING MORE
SICK DAYS IS GOOD NOT JUST FOR
THE WORKERS BEFORE THE EMPLOYERS.
YOU DON'T ACTUALLY WANT YOUR
WORK OR YOUR EMPLOYEE THERE WHEN
THEY'RE SICK GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES AND THEIR LOVED ONES
AGAIN WILL MAKE FOR A SAFER WORK
ENVIRONMENTS.
HAPPIER EMPLOYEES AND I AND I
THINK -- BUT WILL WILL MOVE US
AS A STATE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION EVEN THOUGH I THINK
THERE'S A LOT MORE WE CAN DO TO
PROTECT WORKERS AND WITH THAT --
WE DO HAVE A MOTION I WAS AT
CLOSING COMMENTS JUST A COUPLE
OF THE THINGS THAT WERE BROUGHT
A PORN ASKED ABOUT -- HOLIDAY
PAY I I THINK MOST OF US NOW
BECAUSE I'VE HEARD THAT BILL
MULTIPLE TIMES AND HAD DEFEATED --
THAT HOLIDAY BEHAVE IN
CALIFORNIA IS NOT A RIGHT AND IN
FACT MOST PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY
BENEFIT FROM HOLIDAY PAY OUR
PUBLIC EMPLOYEES SO I WOULD LOVE
TO TALK TO THE BUSINESSES THAT
SUGGESTS THAT THEIR NUMBER OF
PEOPLE TAKING HOLIDAYS OFF
BECAUSE THEY GET PAID MORE -- IN
THOSE SITUATIONS I WOULD SUGGEST.
I KNOW THERE'S A COUPLE OF
RETAILERS THE PAY ON TIME AND A
HALF OR GIVE AN EXTRA TURKEY ON
THANKSGIVING -- AND THAT PERHAPS
THEY CAN NOT SCHEDULE THEIR
WORKERS ON THANKSGIVING AND THAT
WOULD SOLVE THAT PROBLEM AND THE
OTHER ISSUE THAT WE HEARD IS
THAT.
YOU KNOW WELL I JUST I I DO I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT -- AT THE
CHAMBER MISS CARSON GENERAL IN
AND I I CAN'T HELP BUT WONDER
YOU KNOW IF IF WE DIDN'T.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IT
REMINDED ME WHEN SHE WALKED UP.
THAT SO MANY WORKERS DON'T HAVE --
EVEN PAID LEAVE FOR HAVING A
BABY.
N. AND HONESTLY -- THE THE LAWS
THAT WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA
DEPEND ON THE COMPANY SIZE THEY
DID THEY DEPEND -- ON ON ON THE
PORTIONS OF THAT SO THERE ARE
LITERALLY WOMEN WHO HAVE TO GO
BACK TO WORK THE DAY AFTER THEY
GIVE BIRTH.
IN CAN YOU IMAGINE BEING IN THAT
SITUATION WE SAID WHEN WE PASS
PAID SICK DAYS THE FIRST TIME AT
LEAST WE KNEW THAT THEY COULD BE
ACCESS THREE DAYS ALSO PAID
FAMILY LEAVE WHEN IT DOES KICK
IN.
KICKS IN AFTER THE FIRST WEEK SO
WE'RE TRYING -- TO CROSSED THAT
DIFFERENTIAL IS WELL IN MAKE
SURE -- THAT THAT ALL WOMEN --
WHO HAVE EIGHT CHILDBEARING?
I GUESS YOU COULD CALL IT HEALTH
CONDITION -- ALSO HAVE I MEAN
COME ON FIVE FULL DAYS TO RECOUP
AND GET BACK TO WORK SOUTH WHICH
IS FAR TOO LITTLE I'M JUST
SAYING IT'S IT'S THE ULTIMATE
SAFETY NET SO.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NINE
ABOUT THE MIS KERR IS GOING TO
MISS YOU WHEN SHE'S ON RELIEF.
I THINK YOU CAN COME ON BACK AND
BE A UNION ORGANIZER. OH OKAY
WAS A WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE TABLE WHICH IS A DO
PASSED TO A I DO PASS AS AMENDED
APPROPRIATIONS -- SECTOR CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE.
KALRA.
I'VE KALRA AYE FLORA CARILLO.
DEEP HI DEEP I CAN SALAS.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I THREE OF US.
THE BILL IS THAT -- ALL RIGHT SO
IN A SIGNED IN ORDER UP NEXT IS
A MEMBER CHIU.
DAVID CHIU A. C. R..
FIFTY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
IS YOUR FIFTY WOULD URGE OUR
LEGISLATURE'S COMMITMENT TO
REMOVING BARRISTER GOOD JOBS AND
CAREER PATHWAYS AND ENSURING
EQUITY INCLUSION AND HIRING
PRACTICES.
WE KNOW IN THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD ARE
IMMIGRANTS ARE A CRITICAL
PORTION OF OUR ECONOMIC
WORKFORCE AND DESPITE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT THEY MADE TO
OUR STATE.
THEY'VE BEEN A LEFT THEY'VE BEEN
ESSENTIALLY LEFT OUT OF OUR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT POLICIES.
STRUCTURAL BARRIERS SHOT OUT
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS FROM
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES THIS BILL WOULD
HIGHLIGHT THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
SORT OF INVESTMENT IN ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS.
AND I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE ALL
THE ORGANIZATIONS WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THIS INTERNET OVER TO
OUR WITNESSES.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
REYES MY NAME IS STEPHANIE CHAN
AND I'M AN EMPLOYMENT ADVOCATE
FOR CHINESE THE FOR FOR CHINESE
FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION -- I'M
WITH THE U. EASY -- WHO'LL BE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY ON A C. R.
FIFTY TODAY AND I'LL BE
TRANSLATING THANK YOU LIKE A
WHOLE OKAY TELL YOU LAW Y.
YELLING ALIENATED PUNK ACOSTA
EAMON.
THEY MAKE OKAY UNLESS THE
SENTENCE AGAIN WHAT IDEA CLUB
SOAP AND GLORY SINCE I LOST IT I
LOVE THAT YOU HELD OFF UNLESS
I'M PAUL WHAT AMONG BUT ONE OF
THE THE MANGA.
DEVELOPING LET YOU THE COMPANY
FONG CLOCK LOSSES ON THE LOCAL
WANTED THEM WELCOME TO YET AND
WHAT OPERATING HOGAN WINDING
DOWN HOW YOU TO THE BETA HEY
SANTIAGO FINANCIAL.
GOALS IS ALLEN HELD COLIN TIME
WINDOW DOES SEEING GET
ECOLOGICAL DOT MMHM YEAH.
ED COULD TO HAPPEN SO YEAH IT'S
THE IDEA TALENT CALL GOTTEN HIGH
TO GET THAT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS YOU
RESUME I IMMIGRATED TO SAN
FRANCISCO IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TEN WITH MIGHT THAN ONE AND A
HALF YEAR OLD DAUGHTER. TO BE TO
BE REUNITED WITH MY HUSBAND HE
BROUGHT US TO LIVE IN AN SRO
SINGLE ROOM OCCUPANCY IN
CHINATOWN SAN FRANCISCO AND I
REMEMBER ASKING HIM WHEN I
LANDED WHY ARE WE LIVING HERE.
AND HE SAID WE CAN ONLY AFFORD
TO LIVE IN AN SRO BECAUSE RIGHT
IS SO EXPENSIVE IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND I'M THE ONLY.
WHAT'S ON YOU MENTALLY ENGINES
THAT YOU MIGHT GET SO ONE OF
UNCLE AT HOME NOT TO HAVE ONE WE
FUNDS.
HI IT'S CONGA FUND THAT THE
WHOLE.
I TRYING TO FIND WORK TO HELP TO
HELP OUT MY HUSBAND BUT BECAUSE
MY DAUGHTER WAS SO YOUNG I HAD
TO BRING HER EVERYWHERE AND
COULDN'T GET HIRED.
I LOOKED INTO CHILD CARE BUT IT
WAS VERY EXPENSIVE SO I SIGNED
UP WITH CHILD CARE PROVIDED BY
THE CITY.
EVEN THE EVEN THEN IT TOOK THEM
ALMOST TWO YEARS TO BE ON THE
WAIT LIST TO GET BACK TO ME.
AND AS AN IMMIGRANT MYSELF I DID
NOT KNOW ENGLISH THAT WAS VERY
HARD FOR ME TO FIND WORK OR EVEN
TAKE CLASSES FITTED MY ENGLISH
LEVEL.
NOW THAT THAT THE LIKE THAT
DOESN'T FISCAL CHALLENGES YES
YOU CAN HELP YOUNG MAN ALSO SEE
BOGLE GARCIA I HOPE THE LINES A
BILL WOULD TALK ABOUT -- WHILE
TWO WEEKS BUT BY THE TIME HE
TOOK THE TAPE WITH A VOTE AND
TYLER COULD YOU CULTURE THAT
THERE WAS SOMEBODY SO WHAT DOES
HE GO AGAIN YOU TO HIM WITHOUT
THE OKAY.
SOMEWHAT ON THE LOCAL MONNING
THE NOTED HER HIGH SINGLE YOUNG
HOUSTON HIGH BOTH LOCAL PHOTO
CRITICAL VOTING.
IT WASN'T UNTIL MY DAUGHTER
ATTENDED PRESCHOOL THAT I
FINALLY HAD TIME.
WHEN I LOOKED INTO TRAINING
PROGRAMS MANY OF THEM HAVE AN
ENGLISH SECOND LANGUAGE
REQUIREMENT WHICH ARE THE
COURSES YOU HAVE TO TAKE IN
ORDER TO ACHIEVE A CERTAIN LEVEL --
I FOUND I WAS INTERESTED IN THE
HOSPITALITY VOCATIONAL TRAINING
PROGRAM JOINTLY ORGANIZED BY
CITY COLLEGE OF SAN FRANCISCO
CHINESE PROGRESSIVE PROGRESSIVE
ASSOCIATION AND ONLY A MULLIN
POLITICAL.
THING Là THEY'LL YELCHIN HIM
THEM SOMEWHAT CAUSES SOME
SOMEWHAT LIKE A LOT GOES INTO
BUYING A LONG TIME I'M GONNA SO
HIM WANTING VOLATILITY GAUDY
YELLOW YOU NOT ONLY A HYUNDAI
YOU MENTAL GOT AND THAT THOSE
THAT.
THOUGHT HE GOT DEVELOPING A THEY
DO A LOT OF FUN THANK GOD HOW
YOU FEEL MORE CONTENT GOT USEFUL
MONA THAN WHAT THE HOLD A MONTH
ON HOLD HAVE PSYCHOLOGICAL DOC
HELP MAKE ALL THAT DETAIL THANK
YOU.
I WANT TO FIND A GOOD JOB THAT I
THAT CAN PROVIDE A LIVABLE WAGE
SO I CAN NOT ONLY SUPPORT MY
FAMILY TO LIVE A LIFE WITH
DIGNITY BUT ALSO TO SUPPORT MY
CHILDREN'S INTERESTS SUCH AS
TUTORING MUSIC OR ART CLASSES.
I HOPE OUR STATE GOVERNMENT CAN
GIVE MORE RESOURCES AND SUPPORT
TOO MANY LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT IMMIGRANTS LIKE
MYSELF.
I SINCERELY HOPE THAT THE
RESOLUTION CAN CALL ATTENTION TO
THE NEEDS TO PROVIDE TO PROVIDE
BASIC TRAINING FOR IF YOU'RE A
FIFTY TWO CONOR STATES WORK FOR
SYSTEM TO BREAK DOWN BARRIERS TO
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS INCLUDING OUR
IMMIGRANT LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT.
AND FORMALLY INCARCERATED
COMMUNITIES WITH OUR STATE
FACING RISING INEQUALITY IN COST
OF LIVING COMBINED WITH THE
PROJECTED SHORTAGE OF ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION WORKERS WITH THE
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT CALIFORNIA
INVESTMENTS ENTIRE WORK FORCE
WITH INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT
FULLY INCLUDE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
HOWEVER AS WE OUTLINED IN OUR
MOST RECENT REPORT MULTIPLE AND
SIGNIFICANT BARRIERS ARE
SHUTTING OUR COMMUNITIES OUT OF
MEANINGFUL WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES WHICH MEANS
SHUTTING THEM OUT FROM ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY AND MOMENT MOBILITY.
AND AS YOU JUST HEARD I
IMMIGRANTS REFUGEES AND PEOPLE
WITH LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
LIKE ACCESS TO LINGUISTICALLY
AND CULTURALLY COMPETENT STAFF
PROGRAM AND SERVICES.
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN FORMALLY
INCARCERATED MANY OF WHOM WORK
OR RECEIVE TRAINING WHILE
INCARCERATED ARE UNABLE TO APPLY
THEIR EXPERIENCES. TO
CREDENTIALS AND CAREERS
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS ARE IN
ELIGIBLE FOR THE MAJORITY OF
WORK FOR SERVICES EVEN THOUGH
THEY COMPRISE ONE OUT OF TEN
WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA.
SO MANY BERRIES NETWORK FOR
SYSTEM CUT ACROSS OUR
COMMUNITIES SUCH AS TIME AND
COST REQUIRED FOR TRAINING A
LACK OF SUPPORT OF STAFF AND
SERVICES AND PERHAPS MOST
IMPORTANTLY.
THE LACK OF INVESTMENT SUPPORT
FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS WITH POSITIVE
SOLUTIONS AND REACH BEFORE TO
WORKING WITH THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND AGENCIES. TO
CREATE A WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
SYSTEM THAT WORKS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR SUPERVISOR.
FIFTY THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
YEAH BUT THE MICROPHONE NAME --
FILIATION -- ONE MOMENT LET'S
GET THE MICROPHONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO REMEMBER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KAELIN
DEAN WITH THE ALLIANCE FOR BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR AT POLICY LINK
AND WERE CO SPONSORS PROUD CO
SPONSORS AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF ACR.
FIFTY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE IN
CENTER CITY RAM SANTANA
REPRESENTED CHINESE FOR
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION WE ARE ONE OF
THE CO SPONSORS AS WELL AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT TO BE A MOTION
[inaudible]
IS.
ALL RIGHT THROUGH THE MOTIONS
AMERICA'S SALAS SECOND SOME
SUMMER JONES SAWYER ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS -- I SAW
THANK YOU SUMMER CHIU SOMEONE
WHO.
NEVER SAN JOSE SANTA COUNTY
HAVING THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE
IMMIGRANT BORN -- RESIDENTS OF
ANY COUNTY IN THE STATE -- I
REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE IN THE
IMPORTANCE OF AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THOSE THAT --
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT AS WELL SO
THIS HAS ENJOYED AYE
RECOMMENDATION I WITH THAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
USUALLY WOULD SAY RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR VOTE I JUST WANT TO SAY
ONE THING OR THINK MISS SUE FOR
COMING AND YOU KNOW OUR STATE WE
HAVE.
THE WEALTHIEST OF THE POOREST
FOLKS IN THE WORLD AND MY
DISTRICT IS THAT EXAMPLE OF MY
DISTRICT HAS COMPANIES THAT ARE
IPO IN THIS YEAR -- THAT
REPRESENT SOME OF THE WEALTHIEST --
ENTREPRENEURS IN THE STATE AND
WITHIN A FEW BLOCKS A FEW MILES
WE HAVE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
RECENT IMMIGRANTS.
WHO IF FOR EXAMPLE THE CASE OF
CHINATOWN A RECENT STUDY SHOWED
OVER HALF?
ARE NOT MAKING A MINIMUM WAGE
AVERAGE SALARY OF TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS 90% DO NOT HAVE REGULAR
HEALTH INSURANCE AND SO WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
IS HOW ENSURE THAT EVERYONE
SUCCEEDS IN.
A WORK FORCE IN AN ECONOMY THAT
SHOULD BE THE ENVY OF THE WORLD
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- ABOUT A
CENTER OF COAL PLEASE.
MOTION IS BE ADOPTED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KALRA
HI KALRA AYE FLORA.
CARILLO.
DEEP.
BY DEEP AYE GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE THREE OF US.
RIGHT THAT THAT BILLS OUT I
THANK YOU SO MUCH SOME RICHARD.
ALL RIGHT UP NEXT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE DOCTOR WEBER.
AB.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SLOT OF
FOLKS -- WITH INTEREST IN THIS.
ONE AND AS I INDICATED
PREVIOUSLY UP YOU WITNESSES ARE
UP TO FOR SIX MINUTES WON'T
SPEND ALL TIME.
A DOCTOR OF COURSE YOU MAY OPEN.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT TO
YOU AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THE
PROTECT AMERICA CALL TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA CALL CENTER JOB AT
CALL CENTERS ARE MAJOR ECONOMIC
FORCE IN THE UNITED STATES
REPRESENTING ABOUT 3% OF OUR
WORKFORCE.
YET THE NUMBER OF CUSTOMER
SERVICE CONTACT CENTER JOBS HAS
DECLINED IN THE LAST FOUR YEARS
BY FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND LARGELY
DUE TO OUTSOURCING AND LAYOFFS.
IS BECOME ALL TOO COMMON FOR
CORPORATIONS TO REAP THE
BENEFITS OF STATE FUNDING IN
SUBSIDIES WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
EXPORTING JOBS OVERSEAS.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
CORPORATIONS HAVE BENEFITTED
FROM MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
STATE SUBSIDIES WERE FUNNELING
CALL CENTER JOBS OUT OF
CALIFORNIA.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE
SHUT DOWN OF JUST FIVE CALL SOON
AS RESULTED IN NEARLY A THOUSAND
MIDDLE CLASS JOBS LOST.
CORPORATION SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THIS OUTSOURCING
AND TO CONTINUE SUBSIDIZING
CORPORATIONS THAT EXPORT CALL
CENTER JOBS ONLY SERVES TO
INCENTIVIZE BEHAVIOR.
BECAUSE OF THE JOB SHOULD BE
BASED IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT
THEY SERVE.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE THAT EMPLOYERS SEEKING
TO RELOCATE CALL CENTERS FROM
CALIFORNIA TO ANOTHER COUNTRY
GIVE THE LABOR COMMISSIONER OF
HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS NOTICE.
ADDITIONALLY IN ADDITION
EMPLOYERS WHO EXPORT CALL CENTER
JOBS OVERSEAS WOULD BE
PROHIBITED FROM RECEIVING ANY
STATE GRANTS GUARANTEED LOANS OR
TAX BENEFITS FOR FIVE YEARS.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
AND HERE TO SPEAK WITH ME TODAY
IS TOM RUNYON WHO'S VICE
PRESIDENT FOR ME.
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
DISTRICT.
NINE IN A MOTION A SECOND PLEASE --
MY NAME IS TOM RUNYON I'M VICE
PRESIDENT OF COMMUNICATION
WORKERS OF AMERICA DISTRICT.
NINE AND I'M HERE TODAY SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU CHAIRMAN COLOR AND
THE MEMBERS FOR LETTING US --
TESTIFYING.
CALL CENTERS ARE AN IMPORTANT
ECONOMIC LIFELINE FOR MANY
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
WITH TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
WORKERS WITH THE JOB TITLE
CUSTOMER SERVICE REPRESENTATIVE
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE.
BUT THOUSANDS OF CALL CENTER
WORKERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE
LOST THEIR JOBS IN RECENT YEARS
AS MAJOR CORPORATIONS HAVE OFF
SHORT CUSTOMER SERVICE
OPERATIONS.
OVERSEAS.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN FOR
EXAMPLE EIGHTEEN T. HAS CLOSE
CALL CENTERS IN ANAHEIM.
BAKERSFIELD ATWATER SACRAMENTO
OAKLAND RESULTING IN OVER A
THOUSAND LOST JOBS. EIGHTEEN T.
HAS ALSO SET FAIRLY REDUCE ITS
WORKFORCE IN SAN RAMON FRESNO
SAN DIEGO COMMERCE PASADENA
ESCONDIDO AND TORRANCE.
IN MAY OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
SPECTRUM FORMALLY TIME WARNER
CABLE CLOSED ITS CALL CENTER IN
PALM DESERT LAYING OFF TWO
HUNDRED WORKERS.
IN FEBRUARY OF TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN VERIZON WIRELESS CLOSE
ITS CALL CENTER IN IRVINE.
THEN I'M PULLING OVER ONE
THOUSAND WORKERS.
IN OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
THE COMPANY CLOSED ITS CALL
CENTER IN RANCHO CORDOVA ALSO
LAYING OFF OVER ONE THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES.
THIS TREND IS HARMED WORKING
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS AMERICA.
WHILE ENDANGERING CONSUMER
SECURITY FOR EXAMPLE.
CALL CENTERS IN COSTA RICO WERE
HOME TO A MASSIVE TELEMARKETING
SCAMS THAT THE FRAUD AT
THOUSANDS OF U. S. CITIZENS.
MOST OVER THE AGE OF FIFTY FIVE
OF UPWARDS OF TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
WITH NEW TAX PROVISIONS IN THE
TRUMP TAX BILL COMPANIES ARE
EVEN MORE LIKELY TO MOVE THEIR
CUSTOMER SERVICE WORK OVERSEAS.
ACCORDING TO JOINT COMMITTEE ON
TAXATION THE NEW TERRITORIAL TAX
SYSTEM EXEMPTS OFFSHORE INCOME
FROM US TAXATION COSTING TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN BILLION OVER
THE NEXT DECADE.
AND IT WILL CREATE A TAX
INCENTIVE FOR CORPORATION TO
MOVE JOBS OFFSHORE TO COUNTRIES
WITH LOWER TAX RATES.
COMPANIES ARE ALREADY TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PROVISIONS
AFTER THE FEDERAL TAX BILL
PASSED EIGHTEEN T. A COMPANY
THAT MEDI. TWENTY BILLION FROM
THE TAX SAVINGS HAS ELIMINATED
OVER TEN THOUSAND CALL CENTER
JOBS IN THE US.
WE NEED NEW EFFORTS THAT PUT
CALIFORNIA WORKERS FIRST ADD NEW
LEVELS OF ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE
OFF SHORING PROCESS AND ENSURE
THAT WE ARE NOT REWARDING
COMPANIES WHO ARE ACTIVELY
ELIMINATING.
GOOD JOBS IN OUR STATE.
AB SIXTY SEVENTY SEVEN IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ENSURE JOB STAY
IN CALIFORNIA AND PROTECT
CONSUMERS ALL IT DOES IS PROVIDE
NOTICE OF A COMPANY OFF SHORES
30%.
OF ITS CALL CENTER WORK AND
LIMITS ELIGIBILITY FOR STATE TAX
CREDITS AND SUBSIDIES SUBSIDIES
FOR FIVE YEARS.
I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHIRLEY WEBER FOR HER LEADERSHIP
IN INTERDICTION OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION AND I URGE
ALL LEGISLATORS TO SUPPORT AB
SIXTY SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON LIST SORENSON THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS --
DISTRICT NINE AND VERY STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
LEVINE CRIMMINS PART OF THE C. A
A WORKER WHO WAS IN A CALL IS IN
A CALL CENTER THAT WENT FROM
FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY WORKERS
DOWN.
TO TWENTY TWO AND WE'RE STILL
UNDER THREAT [inaudible]
ELIMINATIONS.
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE PASS
THIS THING THANK YOU.
CATHERINE HOUSTON UNITED
STEELWORKERS DISTRICT TWELVE
CHAIR OF WOMEN IN STEEL IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND MISTER CHAIRMAN
JUST TO SAVE SOME TIME I JUST
WANT TO ADD THAT ON MY BROTHERS
AND SISTERS ARE STANDING WITH ME
TODAY IN SUPPORT.
SO THERE YOU HAVE IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU -- THAT THINGS ARE
DOING ON THAT MATTER I THINK WE
CAN DEFINITELY SEE -- THE
COMMUNITY HERE IN SUPPORT OF A
OF THIS BILL -- ANYONE ELSE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
IF NOT UP IF NOT WE'D LIKE TO
INVITE UP ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY TODAY.
A CALIFORNIA MY NAME FLOOR
CURTIS I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
WE ARE CURRENTLY IN OPPOSITION
TO AB.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN CALIFORNIA
IS A COFFEE PLACE TO DO BUSINESS
AND A LOT OF OFTENTIMES THESE
CALL CENTERS ARE OPENED AND THEN
THE COST OF BUSINESS -- MAKES AN
BUSINESSES WANT TO RELOCATE AND
INSTEAD OF ALLEVIATING SOME OF
THESE BURDENSOME REGULATIONS.
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SIX TO
PENALIZE COMPANIES ANOMALY THAT
HAS THE POTENTIAL OF A PUBLIC
SHAMING ASPECT AS WELL AND WE
DON'T THINK THE PUBLIC SHAMING
AS EVER THE A SOLUTION TO THESE
TYPES OF PROBLEMS.
AND AND ADDITIONALLY -- THERE'S
GOING TO BE PENALTIES TENTH A
POTENTIALLY A TEN THOUSAND
DOLLAR PENALTY OR THE PENALTIES
PROVIDED THROUGH THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS GENERAL ACTIVE
EMPLOYEES WERE TO TAKE.
THESE PROVISIONS TO COURT --
ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE ACTUALLY --
SOMEONE REACH OUT TO ME THIS
WEEK WHO WAS A BUSINESS LOOKING
TO OPEN A CALL CENTER IN
CALIFORNIA HAS HEARD ABOUT THIS
BILL AND HAS DECIDED TO HOLD OFF.
SO I DO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
INTENT OF THE BILL IS.
TO MAKE SURE THE JOB STAYING
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER I DO THINK
THERE ARE SOME POTENTIAL
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES WITH
THIS TYPE OF PROVISION THAT WILL
KEEP BUSINESSES OUT OF
CALIFORNIA FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ARE OPPOSED AND WE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
THIS.
IS JUST.
ONE YEAH THAT'S RIGHT.
I THE ONE THING.
MR MEMBERS NICOLE RICE
CALIFORNIA MANY FACTORS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE'RE
ALSO POSE FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY STATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION OKAY WAS
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE SUMMER JONES
SAWYER.
AND I WANT I WANT TO THANK YOU.
FOR BRINGING THIS UP THIS IS
KIND OF CLOSE TO MY HEART --
WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE I WORKED
FOR PACIFIC BELL [inaudible]
WELL.
AND THEN WHEN THEY HAD THE
REGULATION.
AND WE MERGE OUR FOR AT AND T. --
STARTED THE PHONE CENTER STORE
ON STOCKER.
ANYBODY FROM LA WERE YOU TO DO
IS A THING CALLED BONES MICKEY
MOUSE FOUNTAIN.
PRINCES FOUNTAIN PUSH BUTTON
PHONES IN.
ROTARY PHONES FOR YOUNG PEOPLE --
AND THEN I GOT MOVED. TO THE
RESIDENT EMBEDDED BASE
ORGANIZATION -- REVOLVES AND I
WAS IN A CALL CENTER.
TRYING TO CELL PHONES WITH ABOUT.
EIGHT HUNDRED PEOPLE ONE FOUR
AND WE HAD ANOTHER FOR ANOTHER
EIGHT HUNDRED PEOPLE.
AND I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE. TO BE
IN A CALL CENTER I NOTICE LIKE.
TO TRY TO KEEP THE COMPANY GOING.
I KNOW HOW MUCH WORK YOU HAVE TO
DO AND HOW HARD YOU WORK I DID
THAT WHILE I WAS TRYING TO GO TO
SCHOOL AND DOING THAT AT THE
SAME TIME -- I REMEMBER THE DAYS
WHEN.
IF YOU IF YOU COULD GET A IF YOU
IF YOU DIDN'T GO TO COLLEGE.
BUT YOU WANT TO RAISE A FAMILY.
YOU THAT YOU COULD WORK FOR THE
PHONE COMPANY.
THE TERM YOU DOLLARS WORK AT THE
ARMS UNFORTUNATE THAT A LOT OF
THAT IS NOT HERE TODAY AND I
HAVE. THREE COUSINS.
G. T. E. N. -- AND ALSO EIGHTEEN
T. DEBT ED RETIRED FROM THERE.
IT'S ALSO KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT
IS TO HAVE A COMPANY.
AT IT AGAIN TO HAVE A COMPANY.
THAT YOU'RE WITH. FOR ALL OF
YOUR CAREER.
AND HOW SPECIAL IT IS ON TO HAVE
THAT AND SO I WANT TO THANK
DOCTOR WEBER FOR BRINGING THAT --
AND IF I NEED TO EXPLAIN TO
MEMBERSTHAT DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND.
IT WAS LIKE.
INDY INDY ENGINEERS OF THE
SEVENTIES AND THE EIGHTIES WHEN.
YOU PUT IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
YEARS WORKING AT ONE PLACE AND
GIVING YOUR HEART AND SOUL --
BUT MORE IMPORTANT I HAVE THAT
PULLED OUT FROM UNDERNEATH YOU.
HOW DEVASTATING THAT THAT CAN BE --
I WOULD LOVE TO EXPLAIN THAT TO
THEM.
BECAUSE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT --
WE LEAST TAKE CARE MY MY FIRST
FAMILY AND MOST IMPORTANT MY
FIRST UNION FAMILY FOR TIROS A
SHOP STEWARD.
WAS WOOD -- I NOTICE -- TURNED
IT NOBODY USES ANYMORE
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WHEN MY SUPERVISOR TRY TO WRITE
ME UP BECAUSE I WAS LATE AND I
TYPED UP?
MY RESPONSE.
AND THEN A KIND OF BLEW HER AWAY.
AND THEN NEXT YOU KNOW I GOT ALL
THE UNION PEOPLE MY OFFICE
SAYING YOU NEED TO BE.
SO THAT JUAN UNIONS AS ALWAYS.
THE SERVICE DOLLARS MISSILES A
PURSE WHENEVER TYPED UP A
GRIEVANCE LATE NEVER SEEN THAT
BEFORE.
A BUT I I KNOW IT IS A LITTLE
LONG WINDED BUT I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY KNEW.
THAT -- BESIDES A MISS GONZALEZ
THROUGH SOMEONE ELSE APPEAR.
THAT.
THAT HAS BEEN IN YOUR SHOES THAT
UNDERSTANDS AND I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY.
TOMORROW THE NEXT DAY THANK YOU.
WITH THANK YOU WELL I'M GLAD A
SUMMER WEBER IS A BILL THAT YOU
TO TAKE A WALK DOWN MEMORY LANE --
ANY. FOR OUR BENEFIT OF COURSE --
ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS.
AND I WHAT I WAS WHEN I THINK
THE CINEMA WEBER -- LOOK IT IN
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS WE WERE
TOLD -- HOW MANY JOBS ARE GONNA
BE CREATED BY THIS BIG TAX
WINDFALL THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT WERE BASICALLY JUST HANDED
OVER? TO THE CORPORATIONS AND WE
WERE TOLD IS GOING TO CREATE ALL
THESE JOBS AND CREEL THESE JOBS.
BUT WE KNOW WHAT THE TRUTH IS
AND AND WE KNOW WHAT WE SEE WITH
YOUR OWN REALITY.
AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS -- I HAD
A NOT AN EASY BILL TO TAKE
FORWARD BECAUSE IT CHALLENGES A
LOT OF THE NOTIONS OF WHAT WE'VE
DONE IN THE PAST BUT WE HAVE TO
DO I THINK MORE.
OF NOW THAN AT A MORE WORK NOW
THAN EVER BEFORE TO PROTECT GOOD
JOBS HERE IN OUR STATE.
AND SO FOR THAT REASON THIS
DOESN'T JOIN AYE RECOMMENDATION --
IN -- DOC WEBER PLEASE -- BUT IN
MY SHIRT.
THAT PLEASE ADEQUATE IF YOU LIKE
CLOTHES YES MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK US THE
CW A FOR BRINGING THIS TO MY
ATTENTION -- THIS IS AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ISSUE ALL OF
US HAVE HAD CONTACT MY SISTER
RETIRED FROM EIGHTEEN T. --
AFTER ABOUT THIRTY YEARS OF
EMPLOYMENT BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
YOU KNOW I HAVE A MY MY FAMILY
RUNS TO LABOR IN TERMS MY FATHER
WITH THE STEEL MILL.
ARE YOU STILL ASSOCIATION BUT
THE THING THAT'S IMPORTANT IS
THAT IT IS VERY SOMETIMES
DEMORALIZING I THINK TO WATCH
YOUR JOB BE -- NOT CUT OUT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT THE WORK IS
STILL THERE BUT TO BE EXPORTED
SOMEWHERE ELSE BECAUSE IT'S
EASIER AND CHEAPER.
CHEAPER TO TAKE YOUR JOB
OVERSEAS AND TO REALLY PAY THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK HERE AND EVERY
DAY MAKE CALIFORNIA'S LIFE OF
WHAT IT IS SO IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT WE SUPPORT A CALL
CENTER WORKERS.
THAT WE PRIORITIZE THAT WE WERE
DEALING WITH GRANTS AND
SUBSIDIES TO CORPORATIONS THAT
THEY ARE ALSO THE CORPORATIONS
THAT ARE SUPPORTING PEOPLE WHO
WORK IN CALIFORNIA.
AND SO I'M REALLY PROUD TO
BASICALLY -- THREE THE AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL I THINK THOSE WHO WORK
SO HARD WITH US AND I THINK ALL
OF YOU CAME TODAY.
OF MAYBE THEY HAD A DAY OFF A
SICKLY -- LOREENA BUT THAT THAT.
THOSE WHO SHOWED UP TODAY.
THOSE WHO SHOWED UP TODAY FROM
GOOD PAYING JOB TO HAVE BENEFITS
THAT THEY ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
WHAT HAPPENS TO CALL CENTERS AND
REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ECONOMICS.
OF CALIFORNIAN I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
FOR SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THANK
YOU THERE IS A A A MOTION --
ALREADY ON THE FLOOR DO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS AMOUNT SECTOR
OF COAL PLEASE.
THE PAST TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
AYE KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CARILLO DEEP.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I THREE OF US.
OKAY SO THIS WE PLACE ON CALL
THANK.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WHAT IS THE PROPER LIFE?
I THINK YOU A MIXTURE MEMBERS
THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB SIX
FORTY SEVEN BEFORE YOU TODAY.
AB SIX FORTY SO REQUIRE COSMETIC
AND DISINFECTANT MANUFACTURERS
WHO ARE ALREADY REQUIRED.
UNDER CURRENT LAW TO POST ITS
STATE THERE -- SAFETY DATA
SHEETS ONLINE AND TRANSLATE INTO
COMMON LANGUAGES SPOKEN BY
SOMEONE PROFESSIONALS.
SAFETY DATA SHEETS ARE USED AS A
SOURCE OF INFORMATION ABOUT
HAZARDS INCLUDING ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARDS AND TO OBTAIN ADVICE ON
SAFETY PRECAUTIONS.
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE CURRENTLY
PRODUCE AND NOT A HARD COPY FORM
IN ENGLISH MAKE IT TOUGH FOR
SALON PROFESSIONALS TO ACCESS
DUE TO LANGUAGE BARRIERS OR THE
DOCUMENT GETTING LOST AMONGST
OTHER SAFETY DATA SHEETS. FOR
PROFESSIONALS ARE EXPOSED TO A
MULTITUDE OF CHEMICALS KNOWN OR
SUSPECTED TO POSE HEALTH RISKS.
MANY OF OF THE SWAMP SPECIALS
ARE IMMIGRANTS WOMEN OF COLOR
AND HAVE LIMITED ENGLISH SKILLS.
ALL OF THE CHOOSE TO BE TO THE
CHOOSE TO WORK IN THE SALON
INDUSTRY ACCESS TO VITAL
INFORMATION SUCH AS A SAFETY
DATA SHEET.
IS IMPERATIVE TO THEIR HEALTH AS
A SMALL PROFESSIONAL WORKING IN
AN ENVIRONMENT THAT EXPOSE THEM
TO HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES.
THANK BE POTENTIALLY HARMFUL TO
THEM.
BY ALLOWING SAFETY DATA SHEETS
TO BE ACCESSIBLE ONLINE AND
TRANSLATED INTO OTHER LANGUAGES --
INCREASES TRANSPARENCY IN RACES
SAFETY AWARENESS TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH OF WORKING CONDITIONS FOR
SALON PROFESSIONALS.
I DO ACKNOWLEDGE OPPOSITION
CONCERNS OF AB SIX FORTY SEVEN
ALTHOUGH STAKEHOLDERS HAVE
RAISED CONCERNS WITH THE BILL I
BELIEVE IS IMPORTANT FOR SALON
PROFESSIONALS THAT ACTS AS A
SAFETY DATA SHEETS ONLINE.
AND AND BILL AVAILABLE LANGUAGES
COMMONLY SPOKEN BY SOME
PROFESSIONALS.
I HAVE BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO
BE DISCUSSES WITH STAKEHOLDERS
BOTH IN FAVOR AND IN OPPOSITION
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM.
OF A GARDEN CONCERNS AND SO AT
OF OF OF OF THE BILL.
WITH ME TODAY -- BUT WE HAVE A
CHORE I TRANG MANAGING ATTORNEY
WITH WORK SAFE.
MON TO FARM SO IN NO SMALL
WORKER WHO ALSO HAVE A
TRANSLATOR AND CATHERINE PORTER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NAIL
SALON COLLABORATIVE AND WE WILL
ALSO HOLD A WITNESS IS A SIXTY
MINUTES PLUS THE TIME FOR
TRANSLATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIRST WITH
US PLEASE.
HI I'M GEORGE TRAIN THE MANAGING
ATTORNEY AT WORK SAFE -- WE ARE
CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WORK
SAVE IS A NON PROFIT WHOSE
MISSION IS TO ENSURE THAT
WORKERS ARE.
UP PROTECT IN THE WORKPLACE IN
CALIFORNIA EVERY SINGLE DAY ONE
WORKER DIES IN THE WORKPLACE AND
THOUSANDS MORE LIKE NAIL SALON
OWNERS AND WORKERS ARE EXPOSED
TO WORKPLACE HAZARDS.
AND TOXINS SO AS A VIETNAMESE
IMMIGRANT I HAVE COUNTLESS
FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE NIELSEN
OWNERS AND WORKERS AND I KNOW
WELL THE EFFECTS OF THE DAILY
EXPOSURE OF PRODUCTS AND
DISINFECTANTS THAT ARE USED IN
NAIL AND BEAUTY SALONS AND
YOU'LL HEAR FROM A WORKER AMONG.
TO ABOUT THIS -- WE FIRST
ENCOUNTERED THE DIFFICULTY OF
GETTING ACCESS TO S. YESES WHEN
WORKING AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY MEALS ON
COLLABORATIVE TO SET UP THE
HEALTHY NAIL SALON RECOGNITION
PROGRAM.
THIS PROGRAM SEEKS TO
INCENTIVIZE OWNERS AND WORKERS
TO HAVE.
A HEALTHIER PRODUCTS AND SEE FOR
PRACTICES BUT IN SETTING THIS UP
WHEN WE WENT OUT AND WORKED WITH
THE CITY AND COUNTY STAFF WHO
HAD EXPERTISE IN TOXINS.
THEY HAD DIFFICULTY GETTING
OBTAINING SDS IS THEMSELVES TO
PASS ON TO NAIL SALON SO YOU CAN
ONLY IMAGINE HOW MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT WOULD BE FROM
MONOLINGUAL OR BILINGUAL.
NO SALON OWNERS AND WORKERS.
FROM THIS IS A COMMON SENSE BILL
AND WE URGE A YES VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WITH US
PLEASE.
YES A GOOD AFTERNOON LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M
CATHERINE PORTER THE POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE CO SPONSOR
CALIFORNIA HEALTHY NAIL SALON
COLLABORATIVE.
WORK COALITION OF OVER SIXTY
PUBLIC HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ADVOCATES NAIL SALON WORKERS AND
OWNERS COMMUNITY BASED GROUPS
AND ALLIES AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES.
OUR MISSION IS TO IMPROVE THE
HEALTH SAFETY AND RIGHTS OF THE
NAIL AND BEAUTY CARE WORK FORCE
TO ACHIEVE A HEALTHIER MORE
SUSTAINABLE AND JUST INDUSTRY.
AB SIX FOUR SEVEN IS A MODEST
AND REASONABLE ATTEMPT TO MAKE
SAFETY DATA SHEETS MARK SENSIBLE
AND UNDERSTANDABLE.
IT WILL HELP SHINE MORE LIGHT ON
THE POTENTIAL HAZARDS OF
PRODUCTS USED EVERY DAY BY SALON
WORKERS.
SO THEY CAN MAKE INFORMED
CHOICES AND TAKE REASONABLE
STEPS TO PROTECT THEMSELVES WE
URGE YOUR YES VOTE ON A. B..
SIX FOUR SEVEN AND ALSO SAN
FRANCISCO PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY A PROGRESSIVE UP
PERFECT OUR PROFESSIONAL
HEALTHCARE ASSOCIATION ALSO
URGES YOUR YES VOTE.
AND I I WILL NOW TURN IT OVER TO
OUR NAIL SALON COLLABORATIVE
MEMBER MOM TO PHAM.
AND HER INTERPRETER.
YEAH WE A DIRT ON MOBILE PHAM
THOUGH YOU KNOW I'M DONE THEY
NINE BY MASON -- WALK DIDN'T
SOMEBODY.
SO LONG A BONE FIDE BY SUNDAY
NOW.
BY SOMETIME -- SENTIMENTAL.
YES SOME BY UPLAND THOUGH THAT
I'M NAY MONTHS I DO KIND OF A
NUMBER.
NINE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
TOM TO SAM I WAS A REFUGEE FROM
VIETNAM I CAME TO THE US IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN I WORK AS
A MANICURIST AT SANDY'S NAIL
SALON IN SAN LEANDRO AND LIVE IN
OAKLAND I'VE WRITTEN ELSE WANTS
FOR TWENTY SEVEN YEARS -- ABOUT
OUR ALARM THE BILL BUT NO NAY
NAY YOU CALL THEM BAD OUTCOME
NAY YET THOUGH A BIT DROWNED
BUTTON GOT HEY HOW REAL NAY.
DEADLINE COME YET NAY DON'T
LAUGH OKAY WITH THE NEARLY.
EIGHT DOT COM HEY BIG GROUND
LEAD STAFF I LEARNED YOU YET
WHAT YET HI MONNING I I STARTED
WORKING NAIL SALONS BECAUSE I
HAD FRIENDS IN THE BUSINESS.
AND YOU LIKE TO LEARN THE SKILLS
TO DO A GOOD JOB.
WHEN I DECIDE TO BE GRANTED
KERIS I DIDN'T KNOW THAT EVERY
DAY I WOULD WORK WITH HARMFUL
CHEMICALS?
CLEVELAND YET BOTH THE ONLY BE
FOUND YOU'RE LOOKIN AND PHONE
GET LEGAL KANYON COMES AND ONE
COUNT YET WHAT GET SOME SOME
FROM.
MICHAEL YOUNG YOUNG A YAK UP BY
YEMEN.
CAN ONLY INCOME TEETH.
THANK YOU CAN RUN I LIKE CONCORD
BILL JACQUI CALL MY HERO.
BLOCKING THE LEGAL MAN THERE
COME LAST THING I'M.
I KNOW THAT THE DATA SHEETS HAVE
IMPORTANT INFORMATION ABOUT THE
CHEMICALS AND PRODUCTS I USE AT
WORK AND KNOW HOW TO BETTER
PROTECT MYSELF FROM UNNECESSARY
EXPOSURES.
BUT THEY ARE HARD TO OBTAIN AND
CAN BE HARD TO UNDERSTAND EXPECT
TO THE IF.
YOUR PRIMARY LANGUAGE IS NOT
ENGLISH.
SO IF I GOT A BOTTLE YOU HI
YOU'RE WITHIN THAT THEY BEAT THE
NEW Là COMPANY.
YEAH BOTH OKAY YOU INTERNET
THING YET YEAH I THINK I SOUND
LIKE COME PAY YOU LOOKING AND
PHONE GET BLOW CAN IT DID NOT.
NAY MANGA YEAH YEAH THE BILL NOT.
YEAH I GET YOUR YOUNG BY LEóN I
DOT THINK YOU SAID YOU DON'T
YOUNG THEY'VE NOW THAT LAND ON
THE NOW WHAT THE ONLY THE SOME
COME HARD YOU'LL.
HANG AYE NOT LIGHTLY YOUR BY
SOUTH LOCAL MY BY DAY HOME.
NINE THEY SAID WE A BOB YOU GOT
YOU LOOK.
SB SIX POINT.
SEVEN WHAT SAU ONE HE SAID WELL
WE EIGHT THANK YOU.
SLOT WORKERS DESERVE TO KNOW
MORE ABOUT THE PRODUCTS WE USE
EVERY DAY THAT'S WHY I'M HERE
TODAY TO ASK YOU TO VOTE YES AND
EIGHTY SIX FOR SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
YES HELLO I'M SUSAN LITTLE ON
BEHALF OF THE APARTMENT BERMAN A
WORKING GROUP ALSO ON BEHALF OF
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS.
BLACK WOMEN FOR WELLNESS AND
CLEAN WATER ACTION AND SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MITCH SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
PLEASE A CHAIR WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CATHERINE HOUSTON UNITED STEEL
WORKERS CHAIR WOMEN OF STEEL IN
SUPPORT.
MAP BROAD FOR THE TEAMSTERS IN
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
SEEN NINE ANY OPPOSITION.
MAY HAVE TO MAKE ROOM FOR ONE
PLEASE
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MAY DELAY WITH THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL --
WE'RE HAVING OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL AND
I'LL START OFF BY SAYING THAT WE
DON'T DISAGREE WITH THAT THE
CONCEPT BEHIND THE BILL -- SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR
MENTIONED -- IN A STATEMENT
AROUND IN THE SALON WORKERS IN
ABILITY TO ACCESS SOME OF THESE
SAFETY DATA SHEETS IS TROUBLING
TO US.
MANUFACTURERS MAKE SAFETY DATA
SHEETS FOR OUR PROFESSIONAL
COSMETICS AND THEY SHOULD BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO WORKERS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT.
IF THE SALONS ARE NOT PROVIDING
THOSE MSTS IS TO THEIR WORKERS
ARE ACTUALLY IN VIOLATION OF
FEDERAL LAW.
SO WE DON'T OPPOSE -- THE
ACCESSIBILITY OF OF THE SAFETY
DATA SHEETS OR THE LANGUAGE
ACCESS NECESSARILY -- SO FROM
THAT PERSPECTIVE I DON'T FEEL
LIKE WE'RE THAT FAR APART
BECAUSE WE ACTUALLY AGREE --
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WE LIKE
TO WORK THROUGH WITH THE AUTHORS
OFFICE ARE AROUND CLARIFYING THE
SCOPE OF WHAT.
PRODUCTS ARE GONNA BE REQUIRED
OF FOR SAFETY DATA SHEETS TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE -- WE WORKED WITH
THE AUTHOR OF LAST YEAR ON HIS
PROFESSIONAL COSMETICS
INGREDIENT DISCLOSURE BILL LAST
YEAR AND I THINK BASED ON THE
COMMENTS THAT YOU MADE.
THAT IS THE UNIVERSE OF PRODUCTS
HOPEFULLY THAT YOU GUYS ARE
TARGETING SO WE'D APPRECIATE
SOME CLARIFICATION THERE THAT
YOU ARE IN FACT.
REQUIRING PROFESSIONAL COSMETIC
MSTS IS TO BE MADE AVAILABLE.
AND THEN SECOND ONLY AND THE
LANGUAGE THAT -- IS AROUND.
GOSH.
THE DIFFERENT DIES IN COLORS I
BELIEVE IT IS IN THE BILL THAT
SAYS THAT I MUST YES IT'S HAVE
TO BE MADE AVAILABLE WE JUST
WANT SOME CLARIFICATION.
BASED ON THE LAST HEARING AND
YES TM -- I BELIEVE THAT THE
AUTHOR OR THE SPONSOR BOTH
CLARIFIED THAT THE INTENTION IS
NOT TO REQUIRE MANUFACTURERS TO
DO ANYTHING NEW IF THEY MAKE AN
MSTS FOR DIFFERENT COLOR DIED
WE'D LIKE TO MAKE THIS AVAILABLE.
I THINK WE'RE AGREEABLE TO THAT
BUT I THINK THE LANGUAGE KINDA
MISSES THE MARK SO JUST SOME
THINGS THAT WE LIKE TO WORK ON
BUT WERE IN OPPOSING THE CEMENT
A POSITION CURRENTLY.
GOOD AFTERNOON CALL COMMUTERS ON
BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
AGAIN WE ALSO HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION IN
PARTICULAR WITH THE INCLUSION OF
DISINFECTANT PRODUCTS.
WE JUST WOULD LIKE THE
DEFINITION OF DISINFECTANT TO BE
CLEAR WHAT WOULD BE IN SCOPE AND
OUT OF SCOPE CURRENTLY OBVIOUSLY
DISINFECTANTS ARE USED IN A
VARIETY OF PLACES FOR A VARIETY
OF PURPOSES AND WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WERE REALLY CLEAR
THAT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT --
DISINFECTANTS USED IN SALONS AND
SALON TOOLS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
SHARE MEMBERS CONGESTED WITH
AMERICAN CHEMISTRY COUNCIL ALSO
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED ASSOCIATE
MY COMMENTS -- OVER THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS THANK YOU.
THE CALL RISE CALIFORNIA FACTORS
AND TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO
POSE LISTEN AND THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE OPPOSITION CNN ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE DEEP YES THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIR -- ICE HAVE A OF
QUESTION FOR THE FOR THE AUTHOR
IS THAT -- THIS BILL ONLY
REQUIRE THAT THE THE
MANUFACTURER.
LIST THE CHEMICAL ON ON THE
WEBSITE MAKE IT -- IN TRANSLATE
INTO CERTAIN LANGUAGES BUT YOU
HAVE NO INTENTION OF OF
REQUIRING THAT THE THESE.
THIS INFORMATION GET POSTED AT
THEIR PLACE OF WORK WE'RE AT
RIGHT NOW I MEAN YOU.
BECAUSE FOR EXAMPLE A LOT OF A
LOT OF NAIL SALON WORKERS ON THE
THEY WORK IN IN THIS ENVIRONMENT
WHERE THEY HAVE TO INHALE OR
BREEZES.
TOXIC CHEMICAL -- EIGHT NINE
HOURS A DAY AND AND I DON'T
THINK YOU LIKE HAVE YOU THOUGHT
ABOUT MAKING IT.
MAKING IT TO THE MANDATE THAT.
WILL BE POSTED NEXT TO THE
MINIMUM WAGE POSTER.
I BET IT AS THE THE THE THE
WHOLE INTENT OF LIKE NOTIFYING
WORKERS AT THE AND I ACTUALLY
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS AS
INDICATED BY.
A MISLI -- BUT SHE CORRECTLY
STATED THAT THERE ALREADY IS A
REQUIREMENT.
OF PERSONAL LINES TO MAKE THE
MSTS IS AVAILABLE -- TO BUT
THEIR WORKERS AND SO IF THEY'RE
NOT DOING THAT IN A WAY THAT
SUCCESSFUL THAT'S ALREADY A
PROBLEM AS TO WHERE THE IS THERE
IS IT UP.
WE DON'T WE'RE NOT SO
PRESCRIPTIVE AS TO EXACTLY WHERE
IT HAS TO BE WHAT HAVE YOU BUT
AND DE IT.
IS ALREADY REQUIRED BY LAW TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE TO THE WORKERS
AND SO I'M OPEN TO ANY
SUGGESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE AS TO
HOW WE CAN DO THAT IN A
DIFFERENT WAY THIS IS REALLY.
ABOUT LANGUAGE ACCESS AS WELL AS
ONLINE ACCESS WHICH YOU KNOW IS
IS A MORE MORE COMMON WAY FOR
FOLKS TO GET THE INFORMATION
COULD IN THE WORKERS.
AND BUT IN TERMS OF EXACTLY
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE POSTED THE
REALITIES RIGHT NOW I THINK
THERE IS.
A THE REALITIES OF THE VIEW
GOING TO A LOT US LINES THEY
PROBABLY DON'T EVEN OF MANY THAT
MAY NOT EVEN KNOW WHERE THOSE
MSTS AS IS OUR AND SO THAT IS A
SEPARATE ISSUE THAT WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
BY LAW THE BUT THERE THAT
THEY'RE FALLING THROUGHOUT THE
REQUIRED TO DO AND SO YOUR POINT
IS VERY WELL TAKEN IN THAT
REGARD.
THE VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEE ANOTHER STRUCTURE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THE THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I JUST WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR LIVE I REALLY DO.
APPRECIATE OPPOSITION THEY'VE
BEEN COMPLETELY ENGAGED IN TERMS
OF WORKING WITH US EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY BE.
WE COMMIT TO CONTINUE TO KEEP
THE DIALOGUE OPEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER WE DO
NEED A SECOND ON THIS.
REGION.
WRECKED BENCIC TODAY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CARILLO.
REAL ID HI.
I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US
[inaudible]
THREE OF US I REGISTER THE BILLS
OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT SIR MISTER CHAIR AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MEMBERS HERE TO
PRESENT AB FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE
REGARDING SKILLS CERTIFICATIONS
IN THE GROCERY INDUSTRY.
GROCERY STORE LONG TERM CONSUMER
TRENDS SHOW THERE'S AN INCREASED
INTEREST IN THE PERIMETER OF THE
GROCERY STORE WHICH INCLUDES THE
BAKERY DELI.
DAIRY PRODUCE MEAT AND OTHER
SPECIALTIES CURRENTLY THE
PERIMETER OF THE STORE IS SEEN
THE FASTEST GROWTH IN SALES
PRODUCTIVITY AND CUSTOMER
INTEREST.
CONSUMERS ARE DEMANDING MORE
FRESH PREPARED MEALS FRESH LOCAL
FRUIT AND PRODUCE AND ARE
CUTTING PROCESS WAS FROM THEIR
DIETS.
THE GROCERY INDUSTRY IS
RESPONDING TO THESE CONSUMERS
DEMAND BY INCREASING IN STORE
FOOD PRODUCTION ADDING MORE
LOCAL PRODUCE ADDING DIED IN
OPTIONS AND SWAPPING THE CENTER
AISLE WITH A FRESH PREPARED.
GOODS IT IS THE PERIMETER OF THE
GROCERY STORE THAT CONTINUES TO
ATTRACT CONSUMERS SEEKING FRESH
AND HEALTHY FOOD OPTIONS WHILE
THESE CHANGES HAVE BEEN BENEFITS
FOR CONSUMERS AND GROCERY STORES.
IT IS NECESSARY TO WORKERS IN
THE PRIMER TO THE STORE TO
RECEIVE THE ADDITIONAL TRAINING
OR EDUCATION TO KEEP UP WITH
THESE CHANGES.
A SKILLED WORKFORCE WILL IN
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY THEY PLAY TO
EXTEND ACCESS TO HEALTHY FOOD
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND
REFLECTOR KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE
ROLE FOOD AND NUTRITION PLAYS.
IN THE WELL BIT BEING OF YOUNG
AND OLD ALIKE.
AB FORTY FIFTY NINE ENSURES THAT
WORKERS RECEIVE THE NECESSARY
TRAINING TO ADAPT TO THE
CHANGING NATURE OF THE GROCERY
INDUSTRY.
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THREE
CERTIFICATIONS FIRST THE PRODUCE
CLERK CERTIFICATION WILL ACQUIRE
TRAINING AND HEALTH CODE
VIOLATIONS LOCALLY SOURCED
PRODUCE.
PRODUCE NUTRITIONAL FACTS
CULINARY USED TO PRODUCE AND
CUSTOMER SERVICE SECOND THE
SERVICE DELI CERTIFICATION
REQUIRED TRAINING AND FOOD
SAFETY HEALTH CODE VIOLATIONS.
A VIOLATIONS FRESH FOOD
PREPARATION AND CUSTOMER SERVICE.
AND THIRD THE NUTRITION CLERK
CERTIFICATION WILL PROVIDE
TRAINING ABOUT FOOD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM SUCH AS SNAPPY BT CAL
FIRST.
SPECIAL DIET PLANS SUCH AS LOW
SODIUM VEGETARIAN GLUTEN FREE.
BUDGET RESTRICTIONS NUTRITION
EDUCATION AND CUSTOMER SERVICE.
THIS BILL ENSURES THAT EMPLOYEES
THE PRINTER THE STORE AT THE
KNOWLEDGE AND TRAINING TO
PROVIDE CONSUMERS WITH CORRECT
INFORMATION TO MAKE HEALTHCARE
DECISIONS.
THE OUTCOME OF THIS PROGRAM WILL
PRODUCE MULLIN FORMER EMPLOYEES
THAT ARE KNOWLEDGEABLE ENGAGE
AND PASSION ABOUT HEALTH FOOD
CAN POSITIVELY IMPACT PEOPLE.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE WILL BE A
GATEWAY TO THE JOINT DEVELOPMENT
OF APPRENTICESHIP AND PRE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
THAT MEET THE NEEDS OF WORKERS
AND THE INDUSTRY ALIKE
CONSISTENT WITH THE PASSAGE OF
AB TWO THIRTY FIVE AS A MEMBER
O'DONNELL.
THE SIGNIFICANT ROLE THE GROCERY
INDUSTRY PLAYS IN THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY NECESSITATES MAINTAINING
AND DEVELOPING INDUSTRY JOBS.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
PAUL EDWARDS ON BEHALF THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS WESTERN STATES COUNCIL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR OF
LAND THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- THE ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN STATES COUNCIL
THE FCW ON PAUL EDWARDS I
CURRENTLY WORK FOR UNITED FOOD
AND COMMERCIAL WORKERS LOCAL
SEVEN SEVENTY LOS ANGELES OF
REPRESENTING -- RETAIL WORKERS
FOR THE PAST TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
AS OF BOTH THE UNION
REPRESENTATIVE.
THAT'S THE FIELD DIRECTOR AND
NOW NEWLY CHARGED WITH -- BEING
THE DIRECTOR OF TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT -- FOR THE UNION --
GROCERY WORKERS ARE WE BELIEVE
ARE VIEWED AS A A RESOURCE TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES.
TODAY AND BEING ABLE TO RECEIVE
DETAILED TRAINING AND
CERTIFICATIONS AND INCREASE
THEIR KNOWLEDGE OF FOOD HANDLING
FOOD PREPARATION AND SAFETY --
AND NUTRITION BENEFITS EVERYBODY
IN THAT COMMUNITY -- WE RECENTLY
DID AN INFORMAL SURVEY OF THE
GROCERY WORKERS WITHIN OUR
INDUSTRY IN THE LOS ANGELES AREA.
AS TO THE TYPE OF TRAINING THAT
THEY RECEIVE JUST TO TRY TO GET
SOME FEEDBACK FROM THEM ABOUT
HOW -- CONFIDENCE SECURE THEY
ARE ON THE JOB WITH THE TRAINING
AND AND THE CONSISTENT FEEDBACK
THAT WE GOT OVER AND OVER AGAIN
IS THAT -- THE TRAINING WAS VERY
RUSHED AT TIMES WITHIN THE
INDUSTRY IN OF AND VERY
INCONSISTENT -- DEPENDING ON WHO
THE PERSON MIGHT HAVE DONE.
OF THAT WAS GIVEN THE TRAINING
TO THOSE WORKERS SO -- THIS BILL
WOULD HELP US TO STABILIZE AND
SUPPORT CONSISTENT TRAINING AND
DEVELOPMENT -- FOR MORE
KNOWLEDGEABLE AND SKILLED
WORKFORCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE
ELSE'S SUPPORT.
MR MEMBERS AS ARE GIVEN BEHALF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL --
AUGUST THE APPRENTICESHIP IS OF
VERY NEAR AND DEAR TO OUR HEARTS
AND WE WANT TO SEE OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS CREATED ROBUST
APPRENTICESHIP SYSTEM SO THAT
THEY COULD -- TRAIN THEIR
MEMBERS AND THEIR CRAFTS VERDURE
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MITCH SNIDER WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CAPTION HOUSTON UNITED
STEELWORKERS CHAIR WOMEN IS
STILL IN SUPPORT.
OR ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
THE ONE IN OPPOSITION.
CNN BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THE QUESTION FROM THE COMMITTEE.
CNN MISTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE EXPECT THAT FROM ABOUT THE
YOUR MUCH WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND [inadible]
WE GET.
BACK AB NEGATIVE LEGAL.
THE PAST TWO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA I CARILLO.
CARILLO ITP GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US THREE
OF US HI.
MEASURES OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
FINALLY MISTER CHAIR -- AB
EIGHTEEN OH FIVE AS A COMMITTEE
A BILL TO PRESENT THAT A MOVE
THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- AND IS
QUITE SIMPLY EIGHTEEN OH FIVE
MAKES TACKLE CHANGE THE
DEFINITION OF SERIOUS INJURY
ILLNESS IN VIOLATION OF THE
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY PROVISIONS
OF THE LABOR CODE -- INTO IT I'M
HERE FOR ANY OTHER FURTHER
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FIRST
WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION -- RINSE PART
OF THIS BILL WE THINK IT MAKES
AN IMPORTANT CLARIFICATION
THAT'LL HELP.
DEAL WITH THE PROBLEM OUT THERE --
OF SIMPLER SOMETIMES FAILING TO
ROAD REPORT SERIOUS INJURIES AND
ILLNESSES THAT TAKE PLACE WE
THINK THIS WILL MAKE THE
STANDARD A LITTLE BIT MORE CLEAR
FOR THEM AND CAL OSHA WILL HAVE
INFORMATION THAT THEY NEED TO
BETTER PRIORITIZE INSPECTIONS.
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEN AT ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN ON BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
WE STILL.
XENON WE GOT A SECOND FROM
MISTER DEEP.
ALL RIGHT MISTER DOUGLAS EXPECT
THE ASPIRIN ABOUT.
EXECUTIVE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE CREO.
CREO I DEEP BY DEEP I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US THREE
OF US HI.
SURE.
SCHEDULE SIR BILLS OUT.
THANK YOU VICE CHAIR.
ALL RIGHT.
UP THE FINAL TWO BILLS ARE FROM
A SIMILAR CARILLO.
SB.
SIX SEVEN THREE AGAIN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I AM
SUPPOSED TO BE AT TWO PLACES AT
THE SAME TIME RIGHT NOW.
THERE IN JUNE.
HELLO AND PLEASE.
AT SIX SEVEN THREE YEAH OKAY
GREAT [inaudible]
HELLO.
THANK YOU.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB SIX SEVEN
THREE WILL KEEP IT SHORT -- A
BILL THAT WILL BE AT THAT IS
NECESSARY TO PROVIDE RECOURSE TO
WORKERS.
AND THEIR EMPLOYERS TO NOT PAID
WAGES ON TIME I WILL BE TAKING
AMENDMENTS TO SPECIFY THAT ANY
PENALTIES WERE COVERED BY THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER SHALL BE PAID
TO THE EMPLOYEE.
THIS PAST FEBRUARY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER ISSUE THE LARGEST
CITATION IN STATE HISTORY FINING
AND LA CONSTRUCTION COMPANY
NEARLY TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR REPEATED WAGE THEFT
VIOLATIONS THAT LEFT OVER ONE
THOUSAND WORKERS WITHOUT WAITING
WEEKS AND EVEN MONTHS FOR THEIR
PAYCHECKS.
VIOLATIONS LIKE THIS AS WE ALL
KNOW -- HAVE A INCREDIBLE
HARDSHIP TO WORKING FAMILIES.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO RECOVER THE
PENALTY FOR THE STATE BUT
ACCORDING TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER THIS PENALTY HAS
ACTUALLY NOT BEEN COLLECTED.
EVEN IF THE PENALTIES WERE TO BE
COLLECTED BY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER THE PENALTIES DO
NOT GO TO THE WORKER.
THIS BILL WILL HELP PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA WORKERS SIMPLE AND
DIRECT AVENUES FOR RECOVERY WHEN
EMPLOYERS.
WHO DO NOT PAY ON TIME UNDER
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY THREE THE
WORKER?
MAYBE COVER A PENALTY THROUGH A
HEARING BEFORE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER OR AN INDEPENDENT
CIVIL ACTION ANY PENALTY THAT
THE LABOR COMMISSIONER RECOVERS.
IN A HEARING WILL BE PROVIDED TO
THE AFFECTED EMPLOYEE FOR THE
INITIAL VIOLATION THE EMPLOYEE
WILL RECOVER ONE HUNDRED DOLLARS.
FOR EACH SUBSEQUENT VIOLATION OR
ANY INTENTIONAL VIOLATION THE
EMPLOYEE WOULD RECOVER A TWO
HUNDRED DOLLAR PENALTY PLUS 25%
OF THE AMOUNT UNLAWFULLY.
WITHHELD WITH ME HERE TO TESTIFY
IS THE NOW THE URBAN.
WHO IS THE EXPECTED DIRECTOR OF
THE CENTER FOR WORKER RIGHTS AS
WELL AS CAROL OF EVENING SENIOR
STAFF ATTORNEY OF LEGAL LATE AT
WORK AND INTRODUCING HER CLIENT?
REBECCA DID LIKE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS CAROL BEING AND I'M A
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT LEGAL
AID AT WORK TWICE DIRECT THE
WAGE PROTECTION PROGRAM.
AT THE WHICH PROTECTION PROGRAM
WE PROVIDE FREE LEGAL SERVICES
TO LOW WAGE WORKERS.
LAST YEAR ALONE WE WERE COVERED
OVER TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN OWED WAGES TO OUR
CLIENTS.
WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF A.
B..
SIX SEVENTY THREE THIS LAW IS
ABOUT THE MOST BASIC WAGE
PROTECTION THE RIGHT TO BE PAID
ON TIME.
IN MY OVER TEN YEARS OF DOING
WAGE CLAIMS NOT BEING PAID IN
FULL AND ON TIME IS THE MOST
COMMON PROBLEM WE'VE SEEN.
THERE IS PRACTICALLY NO
CONSEQUENCE FOR AN EMPLOYER NOT
TO PAY HIS WORKERS ON TIME THERE
MUST BE A PRACTICAL REMEDY OR
EMPLOYERS WILL CONTINUE TO MISS
PAYDAY.
WE SEE WORKERS LIVING PAYCHECK
TO PAYCHECK AND WHO ARE NOT PAID
REGULARLY AND THE IMPACTS ARE
DEVASTATING.
WITH ME TODAY IS ONE OF OUR
CLIENTS REBEKAH DID LAKE WHO
WORKS IN THE RESTAURANT INDUSTRY
WE'RE LATE PAYCHECKS ARE ALL TOO
COMMON.
HI THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY.
MY NAME IS REBECCA DID LIKE AND
I'VE WORKED IN THE RESTAURANT
INDUSTRY FOR TEN YEARS.
I'M HERE TO TALK ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCE IN MISSION BEACH CAFE
WHERE I WORKED FROM AUGUST --
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN TO FOR
FEBRUARY.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN DURING MY
EMPLOYMENT I WAS OFTEN PAID LATE
AND WHEN I WAS PAID MY CHECKS
WOULD OFTEN BOUNCE I NEVER KNEW
THE NEXT TIME I WAS GETTING PAID
OR WHEN THERE WOULD BE.
SUFFICIENT FUNDS IN THE ACCOUNT
FOR ME TO COLLECT.
I OFTEN HAD TO DIP INTO MY
SAVINGS TO PAY FOR RENT AND
OTHER BILLS I WAS LUCKY ENOUGH
TO HAVE A SAVINGS TO RELY ON
WHERE SOME OF MY OTHER COWORKERS
WERE.
NOT AS LUCKY -- I'M PARTICULAR
ONE OF MY COWORKERS WAS
THREATENED WITH EVICTION BECAUSE
OF THE EMPLOYER NOT PAYING HIM
ON TIME.
AND ANOTHER ONE OF MY CO WORKERS
STRESSED BECAUSE HE CAN A FEW
THIS FAMILY BECAUSE HE HAD
RECEIVED A PAYCHECK YET.
I'M ON TOP OF IT BEING VERY
STRESSFUL IT IS VERY UNFAIR THAT
BECAUSE OF BEING PAID LATE --
EMPLOYEES OFTEN THINK YOU'RE
LATE FEES FOR MISSED PAYMENTS
AND HOW TO PAY A HIGHER INTEREST
RATES ON BILLS AND LOANS -- THIS
BILL IS VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THERE'S NO EASY WAY FOR AN
EMPLOYER TO FORCE YOUR PLAYER TO
PAY ON TIME -- IN MY OPINION
THIS BILL SHOULD DEFINITELY
ALREADY EXIST WE'VE BEEN IN TWO
AND A HALF YEARS OF LITIGATION
ANDI STILL HAVE NOT RECEIVED
ANY PENALTIES AND NEITHER HAVE
ANY OF MY OTHER COWORKERS.
I STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DANIELLE URBAN AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE CENTER
FOR WORKERS RIGHTS I SACRAMENTO
BASED LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATION.
SERVING LOW WAGE WORKERS.
WE ARE PROUD CO SPONSORED AB SIX
SEVEN THREE BECAUSE UNDER
CURRENT LAW THERE'S NO PRACTICAL
REMEDY FOR EMPLOYEES WHO ARE NOT
PAID ON TIME.
AS YOU HAVE JUST HEARD THIS CAN
CAUSE EXTREME FINANCIAL HARDSHIP
FOR THE MANY EMPLOYEES WHO LIVE
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK AND NEED
THEIR WAGES PAID ON TIME SO THAT
THEY CAN PAY FOR FOOD RENT AND
OTHER DAILY NECESSITIES.
THE PROBLEM WITH THE CURRENT LAW
IS THAT EMPLOYEES WHO ARE PAID
THEY HAVE NO CLEAR OR EFFECTIVE
RECOURSE THE CURRENT LABOR CODE
SECTION.
TWO TEN REQUIRES THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER RECOVER THE PENALTY
THROUGH AN ACTION IN THEIR OWN
NAME.
EVEN IF THE LABOR COMMISSIONER
WAS EXERCISING THIS AUTHORITY
WHICH THEY ARE NOT.
THEY THE WERE UP PENALTIES WOULD
BE PAID TO THE STATE AND NOT TO
THE WORKER.
THESE EFFORTS TO RECOVER -- FOR
LATE PAYCHECKS ARE NOT REALISTIC
FOR EMPLOYEES WHO SIMPLY WANT TO
BE PAID ON TIME AND BE
COMPENSATED FOR THE LOSSES
CAUSED BY THE LATE PAYMENTS.
AB SIX SEVENTY THREE WILL
STRENGTHEN LABOR CODE SECTION
TWO TEN SO THAT CAN BE A
PRACTICAL TOOL FOR WORKERS TO
RECOVER WAGES THAT ARE OVERDUE.
FIRST THE PENALTY ALREADY
PROVIDED IN LABOR CODE SECTION
TWO TEN WILL GO TO THE AGGRIEVED
WORKER RATHER THAN THE STATE.
THE FIRST INSTANCE OF AN
EMPLOYER'S LATE PAYMENT THE
EMPLOYEE COULD RECOVER A ONE
HUNDRED DOLLAR PENALTY.
ON SUBSEQUENT VIOLATIONS OR FOR
A WILLFUL OR INTENTIONAL
VIOLATION.
THE PENALTY WOULD INCREASE TO
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS PLUS THE 25%
OF THE AMOUNT UNLAWFULLY WITHOUT.
SECOND THIS BILL WOULD ENABLE
WORKERS TO ENFORCE THEIR OWN
RIGHT UNDER THIS SECTION IN THE
SAME WAY THAT THEY CAN ENFORCE
THEIR RIGHT TO WAITING TIME
PENALTIES. FOR A FINAL PAYCHECK.
THAT IS THROUGH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE OR
THROUGH WITH THE INDEPENDENT
CIVIL ACTION.
THESE CHANGES TO LABOR CODE
SECTION TWO TEN I PROPOSE AN
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTY THREE CREATES
A DETERRENT FOR EMPLOYERS TO
ISSUE LATE PAYCHECKS.
IN THE HOPE THAT NO EMPLOYEE HAS
TO SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES OF
LATE PAYMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OR AS
MERRY GO YOUR SHE HARD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION PROUD TO CO SPONSOR
THE SPELL.
THANK YOU MATT BROAD FOR THE
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DIPPING AGNETHA CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
CAPTION HOUSTON UNITED
STEELWORKERS DISTRICT TWELVE
CHAIR WOMEN IS STILL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
RENEE BAYARDO AS HERE YOU
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MITCH DYER CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO SUPPORT THANK
YOU -- ANYWHERE IN OPPOSITION.
FOR A COUPLE SEATS FOR
OPPOSITION PLEASE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TODAY MY
NAME'S LOWER CURTIS AND I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
A WE DO HAVE CONCERNS WITH THIS
BILL WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS HOWEVER THEY
ESSENTIALLY CREATE THE SAME
PROBLEM IN A DIFFERENT WAY FOR
US -- BUT WE DO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR AUTHOR AND HER STAFF
FOR WORKING DILIGENTLY WITH US
ON THIS BILL AND FORTUNATE THIS
TIME WE ARE STILL IN THE SAME
POSITION AS WE PREVIOUSLY WORK --
I'M GOING TO GET INTO SOME
DETAILS OF LABOR LAW THAT'S
PRETTY BORING FOR MANY BUT I AM
THE REASON BEING THAT THE
LANGUAGE CHANGES THE PENALTY
FROM A CIVIL PENALTY TO A
STATUTORY PENALTY.
A STATUTORY PENALTY HAS TO GO TO
THE EMPLOYEE IN THIS SITUATION
WE ARE OKAY WITH THE PENALTY
GOING TO THE EMPLOYEE WHAT WE'RE
NOT OKAY WITH HIS EMPLOYER BEING
PENALIZED TWICE.
SO NOW IF THIS INDIVIDUAL BRINGS
A CLAIM UNDER THE PRIVATE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ACT THAT'S
WHERE CREATE THIS IS BACKING A
PENALTIES BECAUSE THEY CAN COVER
COVER THE STATUTORY PENALTY.
UNDER THIS -- AMENDED PROVISION
OF S. BEAR OF AB SIX SEVEN THREE
AND THEN THEY WOULD ALSO BE
ALLOWED TO RECOVERTHE CIVIL
PENALTY UNDER THE POCK ACTION SO
AGAIN IT'S A DIFFERENT WAY FOR
THE EMPLOYER TO BE PENALIZED
TWICE FOR THE SAME ERROR.
AGAIN -- FOR LATE PAYMENT OF
WAGES THIS CAN BE AYE AYE --
UNDERSTAND THE SPONSORS AND THE
SUPPORTERS SAYING THAT THEIR
INTENTIONAL VIOLATIONS THIS CAN
BE UNINTENTIONAL VIOLATIONS
BECAUSE IF YOU UNDER PAYING
EMPLOYEE ON ACCIDENT IT'S STILL
CONSIDERED A LATE PAYMENT OF
WAGES AND SO YOU'RE LOOKING AT A
POTENTIAL -- UNINTENTIONAL ERROR
THAT CONTINUES TO STACK WITH
THESE PA THE PENALTIES AND WE
HAVE PROVIDED LANGUAGE TO THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND WE'RE HOPING
THAT WE CAN WORK ON THAT
LANGUAGE IN ORDER TO ALLEVIATE
THOSE CONCERNS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
JUST TO ADD -- MISTER CHAIR I
WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
STAFF AND THE SPONSORS IN
PARTICULAR.
THEY HAVE A DONE A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE NOTED IN
YOUR ANALYSIS.
ALL OF WHICH WE SUPPORT WE HAVE
ASKED FOR ONE ADDITIONAL ONE
WHICH WOULD ESSENTIALLY ADDED AN
ADDITIONAL SUBDIVISION. TO
PRECLUDE THAT DOUBLE RECOVERY HE
UNDER THE PRIVATE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ACT IN THE LABOR CODE SO
WITH THAT I THINK WE WOULD BE --
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
WHERE IS RICHEST IN CALIFORNIA
HOUSE WITH ASSOCIATION AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO ECHO THE CONCERNS
OF THE -- CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND WE OPPOSE HIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ENGINE BECAUSE IT ARE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
KATIE HANSON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION WERE
OPPOSED AS WELL.
THANK YOU.
BRIAN LITTLE CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION FOR THE
REASONS STATED BY MY COLLEAGUE
AND CAL CHAMBER IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT I'LL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE.
AND SO IS THERE A IS THERE A
MOTION.
ANY FURTHER COMMENT.
RIGHT UP WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND. TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AS A RECURRING ALLEGE THAT CLOSE
YES THANK YOU WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY DILIGENTLY WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS CONCERNS
AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO AT
THE END OF THE DAY THIS IS ABOUT
WORKING FAMILIES AND WORKING
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO SUFFER FROM WHICH
WAY.
IT WICKS DEATH WHICH IS A VERY
REAL THING AS WE DISCUSS ISSUES
OF HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING.
YOU HAVE TO THINK ABOUT HOW
PEOPLE ARE LIVING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK EVERY SINGLE DAY.
I WON'T HOLD THE OPPOSITION
OAKLAND AIDS TIES AGAINST HIM
BUT I THINK YOU WERE IT ON
PURPOSE THAT'S OKAY.
BUT I LIKE LIKE ABOUT.
I KNOW I THINK HE WORE IT FOR
YOU.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST MY VOTE.
I THANK YOU AND WE HAVE A MOTION
ON THE FLOOR -- MADAM SECRETARY
OF KALRA PLEASE.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA.
BILL FLORA NO CREEL.
I CREEL ID NO DEEP NO.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ALL RIGHT SO THAT
THE BILLS OUT -- AND FIND OUR
FINAL BILL.
AB
.
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT OPERATE
OVER THE LOWRY.
I SAW HER CAREER HAD NOT BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY OKAY THANK
YOU THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTEEN SIXTY EIGHT AMERICA.
OKAY.
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
WORKERS ARE PAID FAIRLY FOR THE
WORK BY PROVIDING CLARITY AS TO
WHEN A PREVAILING WAGE IS
REQUIRED ON PRECONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITIES.
CURRENTLY THERE IS SOME
CONFUSION BETWEEN AWARDING
AGENCIES CONTRACTORS AND LABOR
GROUPS PERTAINING TO WHEN AND
WHERE PREVAILING WAGE
REQUIREMENTS APPLY ON
PRECONSTRUCTION.
ACTIVITIES WHILE STATE LAW MAKES
CLEAR THAT PRECONSTRUCTION PHASE
OF THE PROJECT FALL UNDER THE
DEFINITION.
OF PUBLIC PUBLIC WORKS AND
THAT'S REQUIRE THE PAYMENT A
PREVAILING WAGE THE AMBIGUITY AS
TO WHAT IS CONSIDERED PRE
CONSTRUCTION WORK HAS LED TO
CONFUSION.
AMONG STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY AS TWO ONE
PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENTS
APPLY SITE ASSESSMENTS AND
FEASIBILITY STUDIES ARE CRUCIAL
TO CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS.
AS A TYPICALLY ETERMINE THE
SUITABILITY OF THE LAND WHERE
PROJECT IS TO POTENTIALLY BE
BUILT.
SIMPLY PUT A PROJECT WOULD
TYPICALLY NOT MOVE FORWARD.
WITHOUT THE SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION OF AN ASSESSMENT OF
THE LAND IN AN EFFORT TO ENSURE
THAT WORKERS IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY ARE RECEIVING THE
PREVAILING WAY TO THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE BE ENTITLED.
TO AB SEVENTEEN SIXTY ABLE
CLARIFY THE PRECONSTRUCTION AT
THE RELATES TO PUBLIC WERE
PROJECTS ALSO INCLUDE SITE
ASSESSMENT AND FEASIBILITY
STUDIES HERE TO TESTIFY IS TIM
CRIMMINS POLICY DIRECTOR OF THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS.
SO SOME OF THE AS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING TRADES AND
CAN'T LIVE ECHO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF LABOR.
THANK YOU.
BUT TIM CRIMMINS INTERNATIONALLY
ABOUT RANGERS A BILL AS YOU
HEARD FAIRLY STRAIGHT FORWARD --
CURRENTLY STATUTE.
REQUIRES PREVAILING WAGE
PAYMENTS FOR PRE DOES FOR
DESIGNING PRECONSTRUCTION
SERVICES WITH EXPAND ON THAT
DEFINITION FOR CLARIFICATION FOR
BOTH.
AWARDING AGENCIES CONTRACTORS
LABOR COMMISSIONER'S AND AND
EMPLOYEES ALSO.
THANK YOU.
MR MEMBERS AS ARE THE OTHER HALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
OFTENTIMES WITH THERE'S THERE'S
AGREEMENT ON WHEN THE PREVAILING
WAGE THESE TO BE PAID THERE'S
COMPLAINTS THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER TO THE A. R.
BECOMES INVOLVED.
AND PERHAPS A LENGTHY PROCESS
THIS WILL ELIMINATE THAT BY
PROVIDING THE CLARITY WE ARE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KEVIN BACON
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO HERE IN SUPPORT
WITH THE GREATER CLARITY
BENEFITS WORKERS THE INVOLVED
EMPLOYERS AND ALSO HELPS CREATE
A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR ALL
THE PLAYERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE THE SUPPORT.
MAP PROPER THE TEAMSTERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THEY WERE IN OPPOSITION.
HEY WE HAVE A MOTION.
IS THAT BECAUSE QUICKLY AFTER I
VOTE.
MA'AM SURGICAL WILL PLEASE.
DO PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE FLORA.
FLORA I CREEL.
I THE HI DEEP AYE GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I'D THREE OF US
THREE OF US I'D RIDE THAT BILL
IS OUT THANK YOU.
AND NOW -- IT OUT NOW WE HAVE
BILLS THAT WE HAVE TWO BILLS
THAT WE NEED MOTIONS. FOR ONE IS
AB TWELVE NINETY ONE BY REGGIE
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
THE BILL.
IS THERE A SECOND.
ALL RIGHT.
WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT NUMBER WAS
THAT AGAIN?
YEAH THE CAN -- DAHLE USE OF
CANNABIS FOR MEDICINAL CANNABIS
LICENSE APPLICATION LABOR PEACE
AGREEMENT.
HI SO.
YOU MADAM SECRETARY ORGANIZED WE
WORKERS.
THAT AS A HOLLOW PLEASE ON
TWELVE NINETY ONE DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA HI KALRA
AYE FLORA AYE FLORA AYE REAL.
DEEP NO DEEP NO GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER -- JONES
SAWYER I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI.
I THE BILLS OUT AND THEN WE HAVE.
AB FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT BY SUMMER
RAMOS IS THERE A MOTION.
I WILL MOTIONS SECOND WILL CALL
PLEASE.
MOTION IS YOU PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA AYE KALRA
AYE FLORA.
FLORA I CARILLO DEEP.
DIE DEEP I GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI I THINK YOU THE
BILL IS OUT WE HAVE. SIX BILLS
ON CALL SO GONNA START WITH A
BIG ITEM TO THE RENDON'S OFFICES
BILL AB.
FIVE FORTY SEVEN ABSENT MEMBERS
FLORA NO FLORA NO CREO
[inaudible]
JONES SAWYER.
IT'S IT'S A THE SERVER GONZALEZ.
I ENJOY WORKING -- LORRAINE A
BILL.
JONES SAWYER I'D THREE OF US
THREE OF US I IT MEASURES HOW
DOES OUT.
ITEM FOUR IS AB FIVE SIXTY BY
SUMMER SANTIAGO ON CALL SO.
CALLED THAT SOME MEMBERS ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA I CARILLO GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ I JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI OKAY SO THAT
BILLS OUT.
ITEM EIGHT IS AB. SEVEN NINETY
WAS ON A LEVINE.
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA NO CREO.
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I VETERANS THE BILL
IS OUT.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN BY SOME ROAD
OR DONALD.
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA HI CARILLO.
JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI THERE THE BILL'S
OUT.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN BY SEVERAL
DONALD.
WHICH IS.
ALWAYS TO THAT ONE IS THE ONE
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SIXTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN BY WEBER.
RIGHT -- ABSENT MEMBERS CARILLO.
DEEP.
NO DEEP NO THREE OF US
[inaudible]
THREE OF US I NUMBER TWENTY ONE
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY EIGHT BY
BONTA.
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
LARA I CARILLO GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I'D JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER I'D THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HI OKAY SO ALL THE
BILLS ARE OUT WE HAVE TO DO --
ADAMS FOR YOU ADD ON'S TO
SOMEBODY KNOWS.
WE HAVE ALL FISCAL AND ON FISCAL
BILLS OUT OF LABOR NOW.
AND SO WITH A STELLAR SOMETHING
ELSE HAPPENS WERE DONE UNTIL WE
GET TO THE THE SENATE BILLS.
THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH ONE THING
THAT I SHARE MEMBERS I DON'T
WANT TO THANK MAKING A LAURIE
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN WORKING
UNDER. TO THEM FOR GETTING IT
FOR GETTING IT DONE -- BUT MAYBE
I'M IN WE ARE WE ARE WE ARE WE
ALL HAVE DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
RESPECT FOR THOSE WE WORK WITH
[inaudible]
YOU KNOW -- AND SO -- ADD ON'S --
A. B..
AB -- ONE SIXTY VOEPEL.
CHAIR IS VOTING AND I ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA.
HI CARILLO.
THREE OF US THREE OF US I AB
FIVE FIVE FIVE ABSENT MEMBERS
FLORA.
FLORA NO CARILLO.
THREE OF US [inaudible]
THREE OF US I MORE LIKE TYLER.
AB FIVE NINETY FOUR ABSENT
MEMBERS FLORA -- FLORA HI.
RIO.
THAT'S A PERCENT AS WE CLOSE IN
ON CONSENT YEAH THAT'S CONCERNS
OR IMAGES TO ONE ON ALL CONSENT.
FOR ABS MEMBERS YES OKAY.
SO THIS IS FOR ALL CONSENT ITEMS
AS A MEMBERS WILL LOSE LISTENERS
FEDERAL AGAIN ON THAT.
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA FLORA WAS
AN AYE AYE CARILLO AND THREE OF
US.
AT HIS REQUEST I REMAINS -- THAT.
WAS PRETTY GOOD.
OKAY TO THAT WORLD THIS NEXT.
ONE OKAY AB FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE
ABSENT MEMBER DEEP.
CARL IF YOU WANT YOU LIKE IT.
HENTY IDEAS AND I SIX OF THE
WORLD.
YEAH MAKE ME INCLUDED -- THAT
SHE WAS ADAM SHOULD SHOW HIS
COMBAT.
ACR FIFTY ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
SO I AM SORRY FLORA I CARILLO.
THREE OF US THREE OF US HI.
OKAY EVERYBODY'S HERE CALL